je propose que nous commençons
chers collègues nous recevons ce matin
dans le cadre d'une audition commune
consacrée aux perspectives économiques
de la France pour les années 2023 à 2027
monsieur Denis Ferrand qui est directeur
général instituts code Monsieur
Eric Eyer directeur du département
analyse et prévision à l'OFCE et Maxime
darmé économie chargé des États-Unis et
de la France pour le groupe Alliance
cette audition s'inscrit dans le cadre
des travaux de notre commission relatif
à l'examen du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 23 à 27 et du projet de
loi de finances pour 2023 bien entendu
le président Claude rénal est le
rapporteur général qui avait souhaité
particulièrement vous entendre regrette
de ne pouvoir participer à cette
audition mais évidemment les en
prendront connaissance
ces deux projets de loi sont en effet
construits sur un ensemble d'hypothèses
macroéconomiques formulée par le
gouvernement et sur lequel notre
commission a le souhaite bénéficier de
vos analyses après avoir entendu le 28
septembre dernier Monsieur Pierre
Moscovici en sa qualité de président du
Haut Conseil des finances publiques
attrites de préambule je veux rappeler
que le gouvernement prévoit une
croissance du PIB de 1% en 2023 ce qui
constitue à ce jour une hypothèse haute
en comparaison du consensus des
économistes
un autre il considère que les capacités
potentielles de l'économie française
progresserait entre 2023 2027 comme
avant Chris c'est-à-dire un rythme
d'environ 1,35% par an en volume il
estime enfin qu'actuellement l'économie
fonctionne en dessous de ses capacités
potentielles ce qui implique que nous
bénéficierions d'un potentiel de rebond
sur l'ensemble de la période 2023 2027
le gouvernement retient plusieurs
hypothèses qui méritent d'être analysées
précisément une croissance annuelle
moyenne d'environ
1,7%, une normalisation progressive de
l'inflation une hausse du taux
d'activité et une baisse durable du taux
de chômage nous attendons avec
impatience d'avoir vos commentaires et
vos observations contenu également des
éléments les plus récents dont vous
disposez et sans plus attendre je cède
donc la parole à deux différents puis
ensuite à Eric et hier et enfin Maxime
d'armée pour un propos liminaire on va
dire d'environ 10 minutes chacun et nous
passerons ensuite évidemment aux
questions des collègues
merci beaucoup monsieur vice-président
bonjour à tous merci pour pour votre
accueil
je préfère avoir des formules positives
et vous remercier d'emblée parce que je
ne sais pas si le paysage que je vais
vous décrire incitera à des
remerciements en retour de votre part je
m'en excuse d'avance mais je suis là
pour décrire l'économie et surtout en
fait vous nous demandez aussi à nous
tous la collectivité des économistes
d'expliquer aujourd'hui ce que l'on n'a
pas forcément vu venir hier ce qui est
souvent le propre des prévisionnistes ce
préambule étant dit
exactement
mais parce qu'on a une économie qui est
très déterminée par ce qui est en train
de se passer dans les perturbations en
termes de d'évolution de prix or s'il y
a un domaine sur lequel il y a eu un
défaut d'anticipation récent c'est sûr
la dimension de l'évolution des prix et
de mon point de vue avant de poser les
perspectives assurez-vous je ne serai
pas trop trop long sur cet aspect de
revenir un peu sur une description assez
simple des mécanismes qui se sont mis en
place depuis au lendemain du covid donc
c'est ce que l'on voit sur sur la
première slide je ne sais pas si voilà
merci donc en fait au moment du au
moment du confinement il y a une
contrainte évidemment maximale sur la
production qui s'installe la demande est
contrainte dans son exercice mais les
conditions de la demande sont préservées
avec des revenus des ménages qui sont
préservés et de la liquidité des
entreprises également qui est préservée
au travers notamment des PGE de tout un
ensemble de dispositifs qui donnent les
conditions de ce qui a suivi ensuite à
partir du second semestre 2020 et tout
de l'année 2021 un rebond extrêmement
fort de l'activité économique mais en
rebond également qui est très disparate
selon les secteurs à savoir que le
rebond il s'est focalisé en grande
partie sur des achats de bien parce que
au cours et ça c'est une observation qui
se veut à l'échelle mondiale mais qui va
donner justement le la de l'évolution de
l'activité économique c'est une c'est
une demande en bien qui rebondit parce
que la contrainte s'exerce encore sur la
possibilité de consommer des services
les revenus auront été préservés comme
je le disais même plutôt augmenter par
exemple dans le cas des ménages
américains et les ménages américains
étant dans leur foyer se sont rendus
compte qu'il leur manquait peut-être un
certain nombre de bien durables
résultats on se retrouve en 2021 avec un
niveau de demande de la part des ménages
américains en bien durable supérieur de
30% à ce qu'ils à ce que cette demande
était en 2019 en 2019 personne ne
pouvant anticiper qu'on aurait 30% de
demande de bien durable en plus donc une
demande vraiment physique qui est qui
explose à un moment où il y a encore des
contraintes sur la production et donc
notamment aux États-Unis où on voit une
décoloration s'installer entre le revenu
des ménages et la production de richesse
ajoutons à cela une mobilité accrue de
la main d'oeuvre notamment aux
États-Unis parce que c'est la période où
on a fait le choix en Europe de protéger
les emplois aux États-Unis il y a eu un
choix de protéger les employés quitte à
avoir disparaître un temps les les
emplois pendant le confinement c'est un
emploi sur 6 qui est supprimé aux
États-Unis quand l'économie redémarre
les emplois ne viennent pas forcément là
où ils étaient précédemment enfin les
salariés forcément là où vous étiez
embaucher précédemment et donc vous avez
une
âme mobilité accrue de la manoeuvre qui
est propice à une accélération des
salaires aux États-Unis actuellement les
salaires des personnes qui sont mobiles
augmente de 7%, les salaires qui ont
changé d'emploi dans les derniers mois
pour gaz de 7% on est sur une
progression de 5% pour ce qui concerne
les salaires des personnes qui n'ont pas
changé d'emploi donc c'est la mise en
résonance de ces de ces trois éléments
qui sont en fait si vous me permettez
l'expression un peu particulière dans ce
contexte c'est c'est un peu les les
carburants explosif qui se réunissent et
il y a un des donateurs qui s'appelle le
qui s'appelle les pénuries qui se sont
formés du fait de cette déséquilibre et
un autre détonateur qui est le conflit
ukrainien mais le conflit ukrainien
n'est pas un déclencheur et
véritablement des donateurs d'inflation
par rapport à un terreau qui fabriquait
les conditions d'accélération de
l'inflation donc on est dans le début du
processus d'inflation qu'est-ce qui se
passe derrière sur la sur la Slade
suivante il y a 4 mécanismes qui se
mettent en place ou plutôt trois vous
avez un recul du pouvoir d'achat pour
les revenus qui sont non indexés et se
faisant ça vous fait une pression à la
baisse sur le niveau de la demande pour
les salaires qui nous suivent pas
l'inflation au même qui ne vont
progresse pas au même rythme que
l'inflation des revenus également des
entreprises qui ne répercutent pas dans
l'intégralité l'intégralité des hausses
de coups qu'elles observent dans leur
prix de production et donc ça vous fait
une contraction de la demande sur pour
ces acteurs là vous avez une baisse de
la valeur réelle de l'épargne parce que
l'épargne l'inflation n'est pas autre
chose qu'une érosion de la valeur de
votre patrimoine or le patrimoine c'est
le pouvoir d'achat futur si on se met
dans une logique de bigouvienne on est
dans une dans une c'est un pouvoir
d'achat futur de l'épargnant quel va
être le comportement que l'on peut
imaginer sur l'épargne ça c'est un pari
que nous effectuons avec ses codes c'est
que on va avoir une volonté de préserver
la valeur réelle de l'épargne et donc on
va avoir plutôt un effort d'épargne plus
important de la part des des ménages
mais peut-être également des entreprises
chaque fois que possible et donc là
aussi ça vous retranche du soutien de
l'activité et puis le deuxième le
dernier versant c'est que vous avez
certains revenus qui sont indexés sur
l'inflation avec retard mais qui se
trouve indexé sur l'inflation des
revenus revenaient des retraites c'est
un certain revenu financiers notamment
ceux qui détiennent les obligations
indexées sur l'inflation et vous avez de
l'atténuation du choc inflationniste
très enfin du choc de prix qui se fait
par l'intervention publique ces deux mé
donc là contribue à installer une forme
de persistance d'inflation parce que le
signal prix joue peu pour cette partie
de la demande avec de la persistance
d'inflation ajoutons à cela la
dépréciation du taux de change de l'euro
contre le dollar qui vous fait qui vous
entretient une inflation importée vous
avez une réaction des politiques
monétaires qui se mettent en place et
donc là encore en facteur qui joue dans
la récession donc voilà un peu le
paysage qui aujourd'hui nous invite à
retenir une hypothèse de croissance qui
n'est pas tout à fait celle de
gouvernement qui est une hypothèse de
croissance en fait plutôt de stagnation
de l'activité pour pour 2023 et ensuite
d'une lente récupération de cette
activité mais bon comme il y a pas tous
les mêmes mots même nom au même moment
signalons quand même quelques points qui
me semblent assez à ses clés et sur la
slide suivante on voit que quand vous
avez un ralentissement économique parce
qu'il est d'ores et déjà assez fort vous
avez des tensions qui commencent à se
dénouer donc certains des éléments qui
étaient au préalable de l'accélération
des prix commence à être moins vif vous
avez par exemple les les délais de
livraison des fournisseurs ce sont
désormais revenus une situation normale
donc les situations de pénurie très
marquées sur les approvisionnements ces
situations de pénuries sont en train de
s'atténuer
idem aux États-Unis on voit petit à
petit l'offre et la demande de travail
se reconverser
l'offre l'offre de travail la population
active la demande de travail l'emploi et
les postes pour voir c'était décorrélé
avec une très forte progression de la
demande qui était propice à un
accélération des salaires ces deux ces
deux tendances là enfin c'est de ces
deux observations là sont en train de
reconverger et l'offre de travail est
même en train d'aller un petit peu plus
vite que la demande de travail donc ça
va atténuer petit à petit les tensions
sur l'inflation salariale aux États-Unis
mais ça c'est vrai des États-Unis sur la
zone euro le diagnostic est un petit peu
moins bon notamment sur le slide suivant
où on voit que les antispations de prix
formulées par les chefs d'entreprises
qui avaient commencé à reculer c'est à
dire que on a des on attend des hausses
de prix quand même extrêmement fortes
mais on a culminé au mois de mai sur cet
aspect passé au prix désormais elles
sont en train de remonter à parce qu'il
y a un facteur spécifique qui est la
crise la crise énergétique et une crise
énergétique qui est redoutée quand même
assez forte il n'y a qu'à voir l'écart
qui se fait en ce moment entre le prix
spot du marché de l'électricité et le
prix à terme 3 mois on a 300 euros de
mégawatt d'écart entre ces deux entre
ces deux prix donc c'est une
anticipation de ce que l'hiver va être
compliqué l'hiver en termes
d'approvisionnement énergétique c'est
l'anticipation pour l'instant que l'on
voit sur les marchés mais ça a des
conséquences ensuite en termes de
proposition de contrat pour pour les
entreprises sur les entreprises juste de
de slides on est en train de sortir
notamment une des questions que qui
était posée dans la dans la liste des
questions que vous nous avez transmises
sur la question notamment de du taux
d'investissement qui est très fort du
côté des entreprises et des créations
d'emplois qui sont très fortes parce que
jusqu'à présent les entreprises n'ont
pas été contraintes comme elles le font
habituellement en face de de faible
conjoncture les entreprises n'ont pas
été contraintes dans le sens où leur
viabilité n'était pas menacée la
viabilité d'une entreprise est menacée
quand elle est pas capable de faire face
à une échéance de paiement cette
échéance de cette contrainte là a été
évacuée parce que la liquidité des
entreprises a été préservée et donc il
faut regarder la situation de cash des
entreprises est-ce qu'elle se transforme
et est-ce qu'elle peut induire ensuite
un changement de comportement des
entreprises vers un peu plus de prudence
que ce soit en matière d'investissement
que ce soit en matière d'emploi et de
notre point de vue enfin quand on voit
les différents capteurs que l'on peut
avoir sur la trésorerie des entreprises
c'est en train de changer et c'est un
point de c'est un point d'alerte et donc
un autre point d'alerte que sur lequel
que sur lequel je dois attirer
l'attention sur la slide suivante on
voit que les défaillances entreprises
certes commencent à remonter mais elles
sont très basses en 2019 en revanche
attention aux radiations alors il y a au
radiation d'entreprises c'est à dire les
entreprises qui arrêtent purement et
simplement l'activité il y a des
mouvements qui ont été très erratiques
en 2021 et 2022 mais si on prend la
moyenne des 9 premiers mois de 2022 le
nombre de radiations d'entreprises elle
supérieure de 37% à ce qu'il était en
2019 donc c'est une évolution qui est à
bas bruit les défaillances entreprises
ça fait du bruit parce que ça va au
tribunal de commerce les radiations ça
en fait beaucoup moins mais c'est tout
aussi structurant sur le système
productif donc pour pour résumer la
c'est qu'on est on a des chocs d'offres
négatifs particulièrement en Europe avec
une contrainte sur la production et une
contrainte aussi sur la quantité avec
une inflation importée et une réduction
des bilans la hausse des taux qui est
intervenue ça là vous êtes eau qui
intervenu se traduit d'ores et déjà par
une baisse de la valeur des obligations
détenus par les financiers à hauteur de
20% et donc ça réduit la possibilité
pour les de faire de faire des
arbitrages mais là on parle toujours du
crack du craque action n'oublions pas de
regarder le crack muet qui est le crack
sur les valeurs obligataires moins 20%
de valeur sur l'obligataire donc on a
des circonstances exceptionnelles qui
sont en train de résorber et l'économie
est en réalité à la recherche d'un
nouvel équilibre et les écarts vont se
résorber mais
au prix d'une récession sachant qu'on
est on n'est pas d'ores et déjà dans une
récession c'est pas c'est pas ce que
l'on observe mais on est dans une dans
une situation pour l'instant de très
faible croissance qui peut assez
rapidement mieux en récession surtout
regarde ce que l'on voit par exemple
chez notre voisin ou trop rein ou là les
anticipations sont quand même très très
dégradés et puis peut-être pour terminer
quelques observations sur sur les
finances publiques je vois que j'ai déjà
été beaucoup trop long je vous prie de
bien vouloir m'en excuser donc sur les
trajectoires long terme gardons quand
même quatre marqueurs assez importants
c'est qu'on a devant on a un
ralentissement démographique qui est
déjà là le ralentissement démographique
c'est le fait que la population active
ne progresse plus pardon la population
nage de travailler recule depuis 2011 et
la population active est quasiment à
plat désormais on a un affaiblissement
des gains de productivité et sur la
période récente on ne sait pas encore
s'il y aura une perte permanente de
productivité mais on a vu faiblir très
fortement les gain de productivité qui
ont même été négatifs depuis le passage
du covid mais là encore il va falloir
voir comment l'économie va se
rééquilibrer
on a la nécessité d'accélérer la
décarbonation ça n'est pas un facteur de
croissance potentielle additionnelle
mais c'est une réallocation d'objectifs
d'investissement et les conditions de
financement sont plus difficiles les
taux sont partis pour être plus élevés
un peu plus longtemps sur la trajectoire
que l'on retient en terme de PIB et de
pipotentielle donc en bleu c'est la
trajectoire du gouvernement qui marque
un écart de production encore positif
entre le pipotentiel qui en tirait le
niveau du pipotentiel et le niveau du
Pipe projeté par le gouvernement donc il
y a il y aura encore un écart de
production nous considérons avec ses
codes que cet écart de production est
résorbé au regard des tensions fortes
sur l'activité des taux d'utilisation de
production de capacité de production qui
sont très élevées nous considérons qu'à
ce jour il n'y a plus de potentiel de de
rattrapage les tensions sont là pour
plutôt aller dans le sens de cette de
cette fermeture des cartes de production
nous anticipons plutôt une croissance
potentielle aux environs de 9 0,9% et
non pas 9% pardon
0,9% par an moyenne parce que on acte
des gains de productivité en fait on
prolonge les gains de productivité que
l'on avait précédemment et quand aux
autres composantes qui forment la
croissance potentielle à savoir
l'évolution des quantités d'emplois
l'évolution des quantités de capital
parce que les quantités d'emplois comme
je vous l'ai dit la population active ne
progresse plus donc on peut avoir une
progression de taux d'activité et de ce
point de vue tous ceux qui permettra
d'augmenter
le taux d'activité notamment pour les
catégories de population c'est le plus
faible vous m'aurez compris les salariés
les plus âgés et bien de tous ces
éléments là seront positifs pour la
croissance potentielle mais sur la
partie capitale il faut bien être
conscient aussi que la transition
énergétique qu'il faut faire ça très
clairement la transition énergétique il
faut faire c'est aussi de la destruction
accélérée du capital c'est aussi une un
amortissement plus fort sans en
remplacement simplement de capital et
sans augmentation de la quantité de
capital dont dispose économique pour
produire donc c'est ce sont des éléments
qui nous invitent à retenir des
hypothèses très prudentes sur la
croissance potentielle sachant aussi que
chaque passage aurait session a abîmé en
général le potentiel je passerai
peut-être sur le solde le sol de public
peut-être qu'on pourra revenir la dessus
mais en tout cas si on traduit notre
scénario de croissance potentielle et de
convergence vers le potentiel qui est la
même hypothèse du gouvernement et c'est
celle aussi que nous faisons à l'horizon
2027 mais pas un même niveau pas avec un
amerithme de croissance potentielle donc
cela nous amène à ces à ces indications
en termes de solde public donc en bleu
le scénario du gouvernement et on range
le scénario alternatif que nous que nous
privilégions pour l'instant qu'il a
encore est un scénario qui se veut
prudent et en termes de dettes publiques
ça nous amène à 120 points de PIB pour
l'année 2000-2027 contre 112
actuellement
bien merci je vous avais prévenu
pour cette exposé Monsieur
Eric Heyer on vous demandant de essayer
de contenir dans le temps imparti merci
beaucoup
les sénateurs donc elle est très
rapidement Denis a dit beaucoup de
choses donc je vais essayer de passer un
peu vite on n'a pas moyen d'avoir la
masse sur les rapidité bon tant pis donc
globalement j'essaie d'être un peu plus
scolaire que que Denis en répondant un
peu plus au collant un peu plus aux
questions mais elle est allons-y donc le
sur la croissance à très court terme
alors bon là je rappelle vite les faits
la France vient juste de rattraper enfin
ça fait quand même un semestre et demi
qu'on a rattrapé le niveau d'activité
d'avant crise et voyez que vous avez un
plateau depuis depuis un petit moment
bon quand on se compare aux autres bon
c'est pas c'est pas si mal que ça vous
voyez il y a vraiment que les États-Unis
qui font mieux que nous mais un certain
nombre de pays qui sont encore un peu
plus à la traîne alors il faut
relativiser ce ce diagnostic par deux
éléments qui sont suivants voilà d'abord
si on est revenu au niveau macro au
niveau d'avant crise il y a des secteurs
qui sont encore en crise et donc
l'industrie typiquement il y a encore 6%
en dessous du niveau d'avant crise la
construction plus de 3% etc et donc
c'est les services qui sont au dessus et
l'industrie et la construction en
dessous et l'énergie c'est un peu
particulier aujourd'hui avec la crise
que l'on connaît et ça peut être que
transitoire et si on rentre c'est le
slide suivant un peu plus en détail nous
ce qui nous inquiète énormément et ça
peut potentiellement avoir une incidence
sur le potentiel c'est le matériel de
transport qui est dans un état assez
catastrophique alors est-ce que c'est
structurel conjoncturel c'est bien des
questions mais on voit que ça marque y
compris le commerce extérieur et les
parts de marché donc je vais un peu plus
vite si on va suivre donc Denis on a
parlé mais voyez dans le très court
terme on essaye tout de même de regarder
ce que nous disent des chefs
d'entreprise et d'en inférer des taux de
croissance vous voyez malgré toutes les
incertitudes qu'il y a aujourd'hui
malgré toutes les catastrophes les chefs
d'entreprises quand même ont encore un
moral qui est au-dessus de la moyenne
que ça soit dans l'industrie vous voyez
on est à 6% en dessous du niveau d'avant
crise et pourtant le moral des
industriels et au-dessus de la moyenne
d'accord
celui des services au-dessus vous êtes
alors un peu plus vite voilà et donc et
le bâtiment qui est encore très utile
quand vous mettez ça dans un modèle
d'accord et vous essayez d'en afférer
des taux de croissance je pense que je
sais pas si vous avez auditionné l'Insee
mais qui fait à peu près cet exercice
ça vous fait des taux de croissance
positifs pour les trimestres à venir on
peut pas en inférer une récession
d'accord donc dans le très court terme
au T3 et au T4 vous voyez c'est un peu
ce que nous diminuez dans ces notes de
conjoncture on peut pas si on croit ces
indicateurs
penser qu'il y aura une réception demain
ou alors il va falloir qu'on trouve un
autre élément alors pourquoi ils ont
moral enfin c'est un diagnostic très
rapide et quand on parle à l'emploi il
faut l'avoir en tête c'est le slice
suivant pour le coup c'est que les
carnets de commandes sont plats à
craquer vous voyez habituellement les
cas des commandes quel que soit le pays
ça tournait il y avait à peu près trois
mois de production dans les carnets de
commandes là on est plutôt entre 5 et 7
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a l'activité
quand même qui est un peu latente et
voilà aujourd'hui en fait on a un
problème pour produire mais pas pour
vendre et donc on a un problème à cause
des problèmes d'approvisionnement on en
dira un mot des difficultés de
recrutement potentiellement mais pas
parce que dans l'industrie c'est
essentiellement les difficultés de
d'approvisionnement plus que de
recrutement donc non c'est plus dans les
services mais du coup ça veut
potentiellement dire et ça sera
important quand on parlera de l'emploi
qui a une réserve quelque part et que
les chefs d'entreprise garde la main
d'oeuvre parce qu'il y a la production à
venir d'accord qui qui sont qui déjà
acté donc si on va dans le slide suivant
l'autre point qui est extrêmement
important c'est que comme l'a dit Denis
on a peu pro préserver le revenu des
ménages pendant la crise on les a
empêché en partie de consommer donc il y
a une surépargne une surait pas une
épargne une sur épargne qui sait
accumulée en France en 2021 c'est 166
milliards d'euros et la Banque de France
nous dit là au sommet c'est plutôt 170
milliards c'est énorme ça représente 11
points de revenus des ménages d'accord
et vous voyez ça serait pas un peu
partout dans le monde de venir en parler
pour les Etats-Unis vous voyez ça fait
2600 milliards de un jour ou l'autre
c'était sur épargne va bien aller
quelque part d'accord pour l'instant
elles sont plus ou moins sur les comptes
en banque d'accord donc soit ça retombe
dans la consommation et là bien sûr que
l'inflation va être gigantesque mais la
croissance aussi soit ça va dans
l'investissement des entreprises ça va
se passer en action en obligations soit
dans la dette publique mais voyez on
peut pas faire comme si ça ne serait pas
n'existait pas et c'est un peu ce que
l'on fait dans nos prévisions puisqu'on
ne sait pas dire avec précision ce que
vont faire les ménages de cette
surépargne on hésite et voyez c'est le
slide suivant je rappelle juste là il y
a un an quand on fait les prévisions
pour 2022 la prévision qui faisait
consensus c'était 4 % de croissance pour
2022 d'accord sans utilisation de cette
surépargne et donc quand on s'amusait
quand on essaie d'évaluer à l'OMSE vous
voyez on partait de l'hypothèse que 20%
de cette surépargne uniquement 20% aller
retourner dans la consommation vous
passiez de 4 à 6% en France et la
personne trouvait ça exagéré 4% de
croissance vous voyez ça vous dit un
petit mot quand même sur le potentiel de
rebond qui était quand même présent sans
tension inflationniste sous-jacente
d'accord attention impressionniste qui
venait juste d'un et je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de parler d'inflation pendant un
moment il faut parler de niveau de prix
vous voyez quand ce que a dit Denis
quand vous avez un choc de demande et
d'offres concomitant dans un premier
temps les prix baissent d'accord et puis
les prix et donc ça fait de l'inflation
parce que les prix remontent mais quand
vous quand on regardait les prix de 2000
qui étaient prévus en 2022 par rapport à
2019 et pas par rapport à 2021
l'inflation était sous contrôle d'accord
l'inflation venait parce que on en 2020
et en 2021 les prix étaient plus bas que
la normale d'accord donc attention un il
faut arrêter de parler de taux de
croissance dans un premier temps quand
on a connu une année 2020 avec -8 bien
entendu qu'il y aura un robot à plus 6
et ça veut rien dire c'est le niveau qui
compte et pareil pour les prix c'est le
niveau qui compte et je dirais un mot
sur l'inflation à la fin je pense que la
banque centrale a raison de dire que
l'inflation va se tarir mais la question
c'est à quel niveau de prix et le et mon
sentiment c'est qu'il y a une marge
d'escalier sur les prix donc oui les
prix vont rester élevés mais avec une
progression de ces prix faible ou en
tout cas faible en cohérence avec le
bilan de la banque avec l'objectif de la
Banque centrale mais c'est le niveau qui
va compter plus que plus que le taux de
croissance on passe au stade suivant
vous voyez du coup globalement ce qui a
changé vous voyez en 2022 ça devait être
une énorme année ça devait être 4 % de
croissance et voyez quand on fait -8
mais qu'après on fait plus 6 plus 4 on
devait nettement dépasser le niveau qui
était qui était prévu bon qu'est-ce qui
s'est en fait en gros si je prends une
métaphore je veux dire vous êtes tous
joué au flipper mais on avait lancé la
bille du flipper très vite d'accord et
cette bille est allée frapper des
champignons pendant toute l'année 2022
d'accord ce premier champignon c'est au
micro bien entendu que au micro on
n'était pas anticipé on verra bah au
micro-ondes à une incidence sur le taux
d'absence dans les entreprises et donc
début d'année 2022 c'est marqué pour
micro-ondes l'année 2022 est marqué
aussi par le zéro covid chinois qui
n'était pas tellement anticipé on
pensait que comme tout le monde les pays
maintenant pouvaient vivre avec la covid
et donc pouvait produire et pouvait
consommer avec la covid
son médecin n'a pas fonctionné et donc
la stratégie zéro covid a provoqué un
une rupture dans les chaînes
d'approvisionnement qui était pas
anticipé il y a un an l'autre choc bien
entendu c'est la guerre en Ukraine qui
on peut dire tout ce que l'on veut il
était pas anticipé même si on pouvait le
crainte personne ne pouvait le mettre
dans ses prévisions et c'est ça qui fait
une grande partie de l'inflation vous
voyez les prix de l'énergie n'étaient
pas en 2021 à des prix très élevés
d'accord et on s'attendait pas à ces
prix là oui donc ça c'est bien le
conflit
ukrainien qui font que d'un coup les
prix de l'énergie vous voyez c'est sur
le pétrole c'est pas spectaculaire parce
que entre nous sans 110 dollars le baril
on l'a déjà connu d'accord mais on était
plutôt sur des hypothèses à 70 bon ça
fait un peu un premier choc mais sur le
gaz bien entendu qu'on passe de de de de
25 à 200 bon mais bien sûr que là le
choc mais on peut pas dire que c'est une
question de tension entre l'offre et la
demande ça n'a rien à voir entre l'offre
et la demande c'est bien des tensions
qui sont liées à un conflit ukrainien
alors vous voyez quelles sont les
prévisions aujourd'hui si vous voulez
comprendre finalement nos prénoms ben
oui on stabilise au dernier point connu
parce qu'on n'en sait rien entre nous
d'accord mais c'est sans doute faux
cette façon de faire et donc vous voyez
comment il faut lire les chiffres que je
vais vous lire et ben on stabilise dans
nos prévisions à 200 le prix du gaz mais
vous voyez aujourd'hui il est en dessous
d'accord bon quel est le point
d'atterrissage
et le prix du baril on l'a stabilisé à
100 parce que c'était le dernier point
connu d'accord bon voilà mais bien
entendu que ça ça va être énormément
inflationniste mais voyez dans nos
prévisions puisqu'on stabilise des prix
pendant 18 mois l'inflation disparaît
l'inflation énergétique va disparaître
puisqu'on stabilise les prix
et donc en fait c'est le niveau qui
compte c'est à dire qu'on va dire
l'inflation énergétique a disparu en
2023 puisqu'on stabilise tous les prix
mais par contre le niveau des prix est
un niveau extrêmement élevé donc pour
les entreprises qui comptent c'est pas
l'inflation quelque part c'est le niveau
de ses prix d'accord donc attention on
pourrait très bien dire bravo
l'inflation a disparu mais attention à
quel niveau des prix on a atterri
d'accord donc si je continue voilà donc
bien entendu ce qui était pas anticipé
mais avec ce retour massif de
l'inflation c'est une réaction des
politiques monétaires très rapide qui
n'était pas dans nos prévisions d'accord
mais tout ça s'enchaîne vous voyez et
c'est encore dans la boule de flipper
qui se fait marseillaise en fait par ce
champignon et qui et qui fait que cette
boule va un peu dans des dans des zones
un tout petit peu un incontrôlable et
donc oui ce choc de taux vous voyez il y
a une sorte de rapidité quand même de
l'augmentation des taux un peu partout
d'abord aux États-Unis puis
bande d'Angleterre et ensuite en banque
centrale vous voyez un point de hausse
de taux d'intérêt ça fait 0,4 de
croissance en moins
et pour l'inflation 01 donc vous voyez
ça ne rime à rien de vouloir le faire
pour maîtriser l'inflation puisque vous
voyez ça ne ça enlève que 0,1
d'inflation et on est à 10 en revanche
ça permet d'ancrer les anticipations
d'inflation ça veut dire la banque
centrale va lutter contre l'inflation
donc nous vous inquiétez pas mais à
court terme ça provoque une récession
d'accord et donc c'est pas cette
politique qui vous permet à court terme
de lutter contre l'inflation c'est la
politique budgétaire d'accord c'est la
politique budgétaire qui aujourd'hui
permet d'avoir trois points d'inflation
en moins vous voyez c'est parce qu'on
fait un bouclier tarifaire c'est pas
parce que la banque centrale a augmenté
cette eau d'accord donc la politique
budgétaire à court terme joue le rôle de
bouclier infasionniste et la politique
monétaire avec ses hausse de taux n'a
aucune incidence sur le court terme
autre que récessive mais essaye d'en
créer les antivasions à moyen long terme
et j'ai pas mis le graphique mais
effectivement aujourd'hui on peut dire
oui elle y arrive puisque les
anticipations d'inflation à 5 ans en
zone euro sont bon mais voilà c'est
maîtrisé en tout cas proche de la cible
et pour la fête à deux et demi c'est
maîtrisée mais attention à court terme
bien sûr que ça sera un choc donc du
coup quand je cumule tout cela je
trouvais que le slide suivant non alors
les problèmes d'approvisionnement pardon
oui bah ils étaient montés à des niveaux
historiques oui bon ça c'est
l'indicateur que tout le monde regarde
maintenant calculer par la fête vous
voyez quand vous êtes à un écart type
habituellement un choc
d'approvisionnement ça faisait un
problème de un écarté dès qu'on
dépassait un écart type dans ces calculs
on considérait qu'il y avait une rupture
dans la chaîne d'approvisionnement on
est monté à 4 écart-types d'accord et
c'est non linéaire tout cela donc
c'était effectivement gigantesque mais
voyez que le bleu c'est les données
connues ça revient assez rapidement à la
normale tout de même alors oui bien sûr
que la prévision
pas assez de dire allez on continue
c'est tendance même si vous voyez on ne
sait pas ce qui va se passer demain sur
le zéro covid chinois on ne sait pas
exactement ce qui va sortir du 20e
congrès du Parti communiste on sait pas
s'il y aura des tensions avec Taïwan bon
c'est un peu ça aussi qu'il faut vous
dire c'est que vous voyez habituellement
quand on fait des prévisions on essaie
d'anticiper les prochains chocs à venir
bon on fait plus ça maintenant vous
voyez quand on en tout cas nous à l'OFCE
quand on essaie de faire des prévisions
et ben on essaie déjà de comprendre les
chocs
identifiés qui sont déjà là quelles
conséquences ça va avoir sur demain
d'accord donc c'est juste cela qu'on
essaie de faire on essaie pas de dire
est-ce que la Chine va envahir Taïwan
est-ce que on va manquer de de carburant
demain c'est on n'a pas les outils
est-ce qu'il y aura une crise sociale
dans les mois à venir on a on n'est pas
outillés pour le faire donc tout ça on
met ça dans des scénarios alternatives
dans le scénario central on se dit voilà
on regarde les chocs qui sont déjà
suffisamment importants et violent et on
essaie de comprendre comment ces chocs
vont impacter l'avenir et donc je pense
que là c'est le side suivant vous voyez
je il y a 2002 22 et 2023 2022
normalement c'est les deux bleus on
devait faire 4 % de croissance d'accord
et puis on a eu le choc au micro qui
nous a enlevé 0,2 et puis on a eu le
choc des taux qui nous enlève encore 0,2
et puis on a eu le choc d'incertitude
géopolitique qui nous enlève un demi
point et puis on a eu le choc
énergétique il nous enlève etc bon voilà
et donc au total il y a des termes des
politiques budgétaires qui ont essayé de
compenser une partie de ce choc on
arrive à 2,6 pour cette année et le side
suivant pour l'année 2023 c'est les
mêmes chocs qu'on essaye de continuer à
modéliser et ben c'est même choc nous
vous amène à 06 donc c'est vrai que ce
06 on doit le lire en gros à politique
budgétaire inchangé c'est-à-dire tel que
il est voté aujourd'hui enfin va être
voté aujourd'hui ou dans les mois à
venir et son nouveau choc sans nouveau
choc de rationnement sans nouveau choc
extérieur qui pourrait le pénaliser bon
donc certains disent c'est une
barre haute d'accord parce que forcément
les chocs à venir sont plutôt
négatifs d'accord même si vous avez
compris que en terme de de niveau de
prix de l'énergie peut-être que c'est là
où on a été un peu dur c'est qu'on a
tous stabilisé à des niveaux élevés et
peut-être que là vous voyez c'est les
derniers les derniers jours nous
indiquent que le prix du gaz ou le prix
d'électricité peuvent baisser un peu
plus rapidement qu'il y a dans notre
prévision d'accord bon si on je vais un
peu dans le moyen terme très rapidement
je crois que j'ai déjà dépassé
voilà bon allez rapidement une façon de
voir vous voyez on regarde toujours le
bleu en fait où on en est aujourd'hui
par rapport à 2022 peut-être que le plus
intéressant c'est regarder le orange où
on en est aujourd'hui par rapport à ce
qu'on prévoyait les instituts que ce
soit le FMI pour certains pays
développés ou l'omce vous voyez on est
en retard quasiment dans tous les pays
sauf dans quelques pays c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des pays qui sont aujourd'hui
à des niveaux meilleurs que ce qu'on
anticipait avant la crise oui c'est les
pays scandinaves c'est même l'Italie
vous voyez quand vous êtes italien vous
voyez pas de l'incidence de cette crise
sur votre potentiel de croissance non
c'est on est même au dessus de ce qu'on
prévoyait d'accord donc il y a pas de de
réalité qui se dégage de façon assez
forte à part quand même on se concentrer
un élément qui est intéressant le grand
perdant de cette crise aujourd'hui c'est
bien l'Asie oui c'est l'orange l'Asie
paye très cher parce que certes ils ont
des une croissance économique et au
dessus de 2019 mais par rapport à ce qui
était prévu c'est eux qui en payent le
prix le plus le plus important alors si
maintenant j'essaie peut-être de me
concentrer essentiellement
le slide suivant sur les chiffres qu'on
m'a demandé chiffre pour savoir si
aujourd'hui l'autre coup de Gap prévu
par le gouvernement et optimiste
opessimisme il me semble important de
faire ce qu'a fait Denis bien sûr mais
de rappeler enfin quel est le point de
départ est-ce qu'en 2019 on était dans
un autre coup de guerre positif ou
négatif oui c'est un peu ça la question
bon
moi je pense que le gouvernement dans sa
présence dit on était dans un autre coup
de Gap positif qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire un autre pot de gamme positif ça
veut dire que globalement le chômage de
2000 de 2019 était un chômage au-dessus
de son chômage structurel et que du coup
quand vous êtes dans un chômage
au-dessus de votre chômage structurel il
y a des tensions inflationnistes il y a
les salaires qui doivent progresser
fortement alors rappelons les chiffres
le chômage en 2019 c'est 8,4
le l'inflation sous jacente qui mesure
c'est 0,9 est-ce qu'on peut dire
sincèrement et sérieusement que on avait
on était à des autres coups de gamme
positifs à ce moment-là que le chômage
ne pouvait pas baisser sans tension
inflationniste non d'ailleurs le chômage
abaissé sans tension inflationniste
d'accord donc je pense que le point de
départ de dire le coup de Gap était
positif est un point de vue qui est à
mon avis plus conventionnel que d'une
réalité qui sort de on pouvait pas
augmenter les taux d'emploi c'était
impossible etc si on a bien vu on a
jamais autant recruté pendant cette
période sans tension inflationniste ça
normalement un économiste qui
s'intéresse à ces questions doit dire le
chômage structurel en France n'était pas
à 8,4 non il est bien en dessous
d'accord nous bah voilà donc notre point
de départ est de 0,6 ensuite à la
question que Dénia essaie de répondre
est-ce que la crise a une incidence sur
le potentiel le niveau potentiel une
crise économique oui mais est-ce qu'on a
vécu une crise économique avec la covid
est-ce que les politique qui ont été
mises en place n'était n'ont pas été
mise justement pour préserver le tissu
productif oui pour préserver la capacité
des ménages à consommer oui on peut pas
avoir non plus tous les côtés négatifs
on a eu des réponses très vite très
rapide peut-être trop rapide et trop
trop importantes mais pour sauver
justement le tissu productif pour sauver
et du coup on peut pas dire du coup le
niveau de production potentielle c'est
affaibli pendant cette crise donc
justement c'est ça la différence avec
les crises précédentes il y a pas eu de
destruction de capital et assez
faiblement ou en tout cas vous voyez moi
je si j'arrête de parler le dofte et la
Banque de France la Banque de France
était partie comme tout le monde sur une
incidence de deux points et demi et
aujourd'hui sont à plus 0,2 c'est-à-dire
qu'ils disent que aujourd'hui la crise
n'a pas eu d'incident sur le potentiel
je pense qu'il faut les écouter d'accord
et effectivement je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il est très difficile d'un point de vue
académique de dire la crise là a eu une
incidence de deux et demi nous notre
incidence on le fait passer par
l'investissement qui n'a pas eu lieu
d'accord l'investissement qui
effectivement n'a pas eu lieu et ça ça
nous enlève un demi point de potentiel
d'accord et donc c'est ce qu'il y a dans
ce schéma il y a effectivement un demi
point de niveau de production
potentielle qui a disparu mars escalier
OK et donc en niveau le choc est pas
violent en croissance potentielle je
pense que là pour le coup il faut être
beaucoup plus prudent d'accord on a pas
alors le plus facile c'est faire ce
qu'on a fait nous c'est de dire bon on
n'en sait rien on garde les tendances
précédentes d'accord et donc vous avez
ce schéma là bon qui ressemble peu ou
pro à ce que fait le gouvernement
d'accord alors pourquoi alors et après
quand on slide suivant quand on prononce
nous par contre il y a la croissance
potentielle va diminuer dans le temps ça
c'est de ni à raison et on rejoint après
Rex et code sur le plus long terme
d'accord parce que il y a effectivement
une population active qui qui baisse
voilà bon tout cela il faut si on veut
retrouver ce que dit le gouvernement
vous êtes obligé de mettre une grosse
réforme des retraites c'est le seul
moyen de le faire
faire en sorte que les taux d'emploi
augmentent très fortement mais même avec
ça on ne trouve pas exactement la
croissance potentielle de du
gouvernement même si on s'y rapproche
donc là il faut bien le rappeler ces
chiffres c'est puisqu'on ne fait que
analyser ce qui est voté puisqu'il y a
pas encore de réformes de retraite c'est
pas dans nos domaines mais il est
possible qu'avec une réforme des
retraites les taux d'emploi augmentent à
court terme et à court terme en tout cas
la croissance potentielle soit augmentée
de 0,3 ça pourquoi pas pendant le
présent ça c'est possible si si c'est
possible enfin en tout cas c'est des
évaluations que l'on fait à l'OFCE qui
pourrait justifier les écarts avec le
gouvernement bon si je si je vais au
slide suivant le gros problème sur la
croissance potentielle c'est le marché
du travail d'accord oui si on oui la
tendance de productivité quand on
regarde dans les grands pays qu'on en
fait effectivement il y a un
ralentissement séculaire d'accord enfin
pas peut-être particulièrement de cas
sur les sur les sur les 30 dernières
années et on est aujourd'hui un peu tous
dans les pays développés aux alentours
de 0,809 1% de croissance potentielle
alors c'est ça qui fait que aujourd'hui
on a un gros doute sur le marché du
travail c'est le slide suivant c'est que
quand bon il est un peu compliqué
peut-être celui-là alors passons à à
l'autre d'accord et qui résume en gros
globalement aujourd'hui si je prends le
cas français vous voyez le cas français
on produit à peu près la même chose qui
a 2 ans et demi d'accord on est à 0,8 au
dessus normalement avec les gains de
productivité on devrait avoir des
destructions d'emplois normalement les
salariés aujourd'hui sont plus
productifs que les salariés de 2019 ils
sont même 2%
supérieurs en productivité qui a que de
2019 et plus que la croissance n'est que
de 0,8 09 on aurait dû voir des
destructions d'emplois on a des
créations d'emplois d'accord et donc
vous voyez c'est un peu ça si vous
voulez lire alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ces problématiques là à part
en Italie on les retrouve donc c'est pas
une spécificité française dans tous les
pays en fait on a beaucoup trop
d'emplois que nous disent les modèles
d'accord une partie s'explique par la
durée du travail
une partie en France s'explique par
l'apprentissage mais il y a une partie
inexpliquée sa partie inexpliquée vous
voyez c'est 2% de l'emploi c'est 6
quasiment 600 000 emplois on aurait 600
000 emplois de trop donc là il y a deux
lectures possibles soit on s'est trompé
et effectivement là c'est les gains de
productivité qui ont disparu mais c'est
pas le donc là c'est pas le niveau de
production c'est le taux de croissance
potentiel qui ne sera pas si voilà ça y
est les gains de productivité à 0,8 par
an vous pouvez l'oublier alors il va
falloir l'expliquer est-ce que c'est le
télétravail est-ce que c'est la grande
démission dans le sens j'arrête de de
prendre mon travail au sérieux et donc
du coup je je ne m'investis plus dans
mon travail enfin on peut aller dans
tous les sens et essayer de voir comment
on peut expliquer bon ok on n'a pas
assez de preuve là aussi je prends la
Banque de France comme exemple eux ils
nous disent le télétravail ça fait des
gains de productivité pas des baisses
donc si le télétravail fait des gains et
ben il va falloir encore retrouver
d'autres éléments qui nous expliquerait
pourquoi d'un coup les salariés français
italien espagnol allemand etc ne sont
plus productifs il y a peut-être
d'autres explications je pense qu'il est
trop tôt aujourd'hui pour pour être
complètement certain et je pense qu'il y
a d'autres explications là-dessus il y
en a 5 globalement vous avez ce que nous
dit l'URSSAF le travail dissimulé qui
disparaît petit à petit parce que
aujourd'hui les entreprises savent que
il va falloir avoir de la main d'oeuvre
si vous voulez avoir des aides et donc
l'URSSAF nous dit il y a moins de
travail dissimulé donc en fait bah oui
c'est pas des pertes de gains de
productivité c'est qu'on déclare mieux
et à la bonne échelle ces salariés
d'accord il y a un peu moins de
travailleurs détachés vous voyez
traversé mais avant quand vous quand
vous étiez en travers détaché vous étiez
pas comptabilisés dans l'emploi mais par
contre votre valeur ajoutée était
comptabilisée ah là aujourd'hui la
construction nous dit on a la moins les
routiers nous dit on en a moins et donc
on fait travailler des Français et donc
ça ça fait l'illusion d'une perte de
productivité mais non d'accord c'est
juste maintenant il y a un emploi en
face de la rajouter alors qu'avant
l'emploi était comptabilisé ailleurs il
y a aussi le taux d'absence qui est très
élevé vous voyez quand vous avez des
taux d'absence qui sont très élevés et
une possibilité d'en avoir demain et ben
à l'échelle d'entreprise se disent il
faut que j'ai des remplaçants d'accord
et donc je garde la main d'oeuvre pour
faire face éventuellement à des
personnes qui seraient pas là ça aussi
ça fait des gains de productivité faible
mais transitoire l'autre point qui est
assez important me semble-t-il c'est
quand vous avez des carnets de commandes
qui sont pleins avec des difficultés de
recrutement vous hésitez quand même à
deux fois avant de licencier votre
personne vous dites si ça repart demain
il va falloir que quand même j'ai tout
de suite de la main d'oeuvre et oui mais
ça vous gardez du coup de la main
d'oeuvre et donc moi je crois plus à de
la rétention de d'emploi et donc à une
réserve de productivité qu'à un
effondrement de la productivité mais
alors vous voyez si c'est ce cas de
figure le gouvernement a tort quand il
dit que le chômage va baisser ça veut
dire que la croissance de demain ne sera
pas riche en emploi parce que l'échelle
d'entreprise vont utiliser cette
rétention on peut pas avoir les deux ils
ont qu'on peut pas avoir ce que dit le
gouvernement disant il y a rien sur les
sur les pertes de productivité et les
gars et le chômage va continuer à
baisser ça par contre c'est
difficilement et donc nous le parti pris
qu'on a pris parce que pour l'instant
c'est un parti pris on n'a pas la
certitude de ce qu'on dit c'est que le
plus probable et c'est avec des dires
d'entreprise c'est qu'il y a de la
rétention de main d'oeuvre chez les
entreprises et donc c'est 600 000
emplois c'est de la réserve de
productivité et donc du coup demain
puisque la croissance sera plus faible
et ben les sièges entreprises vont
ajuster petit à petit et donc le chômage
va augmenter c'est le slide d'après et
donc on a à peu près peu auprou le même
hypothèse de gouverne que le
gouvernement en termes de croissance
vous voyez les 0,6 contre 1 mais eux ils
ont 160 ils ont
115 minutes je crois création d'emplois
nous on a 170000 destructions d'emplois
avec à peu près les mêmes croissances
mais c'est pas la même logique non il y
a une logique de les entreprises ont de
la main d'oeuvre
inutilisées elles vont l'utiliser petit
à petit et donc là les gains de
productivité vont peu ouprou revenir à
la normale dans les trois prochaines
années donc le taux à la fin de l'année
2023 sera de 8% d'accord et
malheureusement va continuer tant que
cette réserve de main d'oeuvre et que la
croissance ne va pas ne va pas repartir
je sais pas si j'ai encore un slide bon
sur les prix voilà bon enfin bon allez
je dirais plus tard j'ai largement
dépassé merci super merci et pour
terminer donc Maxime darmé merci merci
Monsieur vice-président bonjour bonjour
à tous
donc effectivement je vais je pense à
propos un peu plus liminaire que mes
collègues en tout cas je vais essayer
donc juste pour commencer les
voilà merci on met les slides je pense
c'est important de commencer sur les
perspectives économiques chez nos
voisins dans l'épée développée pour
comprendre un petit peu les perspectives
françaises et notamment les perspectives
de moyen terme qui seront l'objet de la
seconde partie de mon intervention donc
très rapidement sur le les perspectives
monde alors nous on s'attend clairement
une récession aux États-Unis d'Amérique
donc avant la fin de l'année peut-être
au début de l'année prochaine donc vous
pouvez le voir clairement sur ces deux
de graphiques qui vous montre le
graphique de gauche la confiance des
consommateurs
et les espèces de barres c'est les
récessions depuis les années 80 tels que
mesurée par le NBA et à droite vous avez
le fameux indicateur produit par le
conférence board qui est en fait un mix
de plusieurs de plusieurs données telles
que la production industrielle les
demandes les nouvelles demandes de
chômage etc donc comme vous voyez très
clairement ces deux indicateurs sont en
chutes assez importante et si on en
croit le passé le passé des trois
dernières décennies
l'économie américaine est clairement en
face de ralentissement forte et nous on
pense rentrera en récession technique
au quatrième trimestre ou au premier
trimestre 2023 donc déjà un contexte
global qui se dégradent et qui est a
forcé à être dû à la très forte
inflation qui rogne le pouvoir d'achat
des ménages américains mais également
par la très forte remontée taux
d'intérêt mes confrères on en discuté et
donc on observe notamment aux Etats-Unis
j'en terminerai là-dessus un
retournement assez assez spectaculaire
du marché de l'immobilier qui est le
premier marché le plus le plus sensible
à la remonter des taux d'intérêt donc
peut-être très clairement on voit un
retournement des mises en chantier des
ventes et les prix ont commencé à se
stabiliser voir il commence à baisser
les prix de l'immobilier alors ensuite
sur les voilà merci c'est la suivante
sur nos voisins plus près de chez nous
quand vous regardez les dernières
enquêtes sur l'Allemagne et l'Italie
donc là on a essayé de calculer en gros
de prévoir en temps réel on appelle ça
n'a aucuns techniques anglais
comment la croissance évolue et donc là
on regarde essentiellement les enquêtes
entreprises mais aussi les enquêtes
ménages et on voit que dans les deux
dans ces deux économies et notamment en
Allemagne les dernières données sont de
septembre je crois elles indiquent
clairement que le ralentissement est
très fort et voire même l'Allemagne
serait peut-être déjà en récession au
troisième trimestre voir l'Italie en
tous les cas on s'attend à ce que ces
deux économies au quatrième trimestre
donc le quatrième trimestre qui vient de
commencer
récession du fait essentiellement du
choc de l'énergie et je vais revenir
très rapidement donc sur le slide
suivant donc voilà on a essayé un petit
peu Allianz de de résumer de façon assez
claire je l'espère qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce soit énergétique
vient des coupures de
d'approvisionnement en gaz russe donc
vous avez sur le graphique de gauche ça
vous montre en fait l'état du marché
gazier au niveau européen donc il faut
savoir qu'on a porté au niveau Union
européenne environ 1650 terawattheure de
gaz donc c'est la grosse barre à gauche
bleu foncé donc ce qui est en train de
se dérouler donc c'est un ajustement du
marché assez important donc vous avez
d'une part le premier la première barre
550 terre à water de d'offre alternative
donc essentiellement les Américains mais
aussi le Qatar la Norvège l'Algérie ont
très fortement augmenté leurs
approvisionnements vers l'Europe
notamment en Italie en Allemagne donc on
estime environ que
cette hausse de l'offre alternative
permet d'accroître de 550 terawattheure
les le gaz donc c'est pas mal mais c'est
très loin des 1650 tarawatters du gaz
russe qui est qui vient à manquer ou qui
devrait venir à manquer dans les mois
dans les mois prochains ensuite vous
avez la alternative on estime environ
100 terawatt-heure de d'électricité
supplémentaire grâce à la réactivation
des des unes à charbon et notamment en
Allemagne donc sans tarabatteur c'est la
deuxième petite barre que vous voyez
enfin vous avez le la troisième le ce
qu'on appelle le self-flashing
c'est-à-dire que les agents économiques
fassent à la hausse vertigineuse du prix
du gaz et de l'électricité réduisent
leur production et ça on le voit très
clairement notamment en Allemagne où les
industries chimiques bois papier métaux
annonce où déjà commencé à
entraîner des des coupures des
réductions de production assez
importante donc on estime que c'est
environ 600 tt de gaz économisés je
dirais par ses coupures ou par sa
réduction de production qui en elle-même
bien évidemment réduction de production
ça veut dire moins d'activités et donc
une récession qui se profile comme je
l'ai expliqué et enfin vous avez le
peut-être la bonne nouvelle donc les 400
tirawatters c'est la dernière petite
barre bleue qui qui sont qui vont être
liés au fait que les pays européens ont
des niveaux de gaz très satisfaisants
environ 80 90%, je crois pour la France
et donc il devrait permettre de passer
l'hiver
suivant suivant le
on va dire les températures qu'on aura
cet hiver on estime que les les stocks
de gaz devraient descendre environ 40%.
90% aujourd'hui encore donc suivant
l'hypothèse que vous faites sur l'hiver
et on n'est pas des météorologues
alliantes c'est et personne ne laisse
ici je pense on pourrait se retrouver
avec entre 100 et 300 TW de manque de
gaz pour l'hiver donc si vous traduisez
ça en termes économique et c'est ce
qu'on essaye de montrer dans le
graphique de droite à l'échelle
européenne donc nous on est parti de
l'hypothèse que l'hiver sera plutôt doux
et vous voyez qu'en termes de d'impact
PIB c'est quand même important 1%
environ et si vous avez un hiver
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus dur donc là
on aura on arrête 300 watts de moins que
de gaz et ça laisse traduire par des
pertes jusqu'à 3% dans des pays comme
l'Allemagne de PIB par rapport à un
scénario hors crise donc quand même des
impacts importants que je tiens à
souligner ces impacts sont vraiment
simplement calculés comme l'élasticité
de l'activité du PIB à la consommation
d'énergie donc c'est comme ça qu'on a
qu'on a calculé on a même pas pris en
compte les impacts perturbations en
chaîne de valeur etc que des instituts
tels que les FMI ont clairement mis en
avant sur le slide suivant s'il vous
plaît donc voilà face à ce choc énergie
énergétique les États européens ont mis
en place de beaucoup de mesures de
soutien au pouvoir d'achat des ménages
mais aussi aux entreprises et donc là
vous avez un gauche un résumé dans les
dans les divers pays des mesures donc on
estime environ que
3% l'équivalent de 3 % du PIB a été mis
sur la table depuis le début de l'année
fin de l'année dernière
dans les pays européens et vous voyez
que la France est à peu près dans le
milieu dans le milieu du parc et comme
vous voyez l'Allemagne a mis énormément
de sommes sur la table non seulement
pour aider ces entreprises de
distribution d'énergie qui sont en
grande difficulté mais également
l'Allemagne maintenant se convertit au
bouclier tarifaire français c'est-à-dire
en limitant les hausses de prix du de
gaz et d'électricité pour les ménages
donc voilà un panorama c'est général
alors nous on est on est assez vigilant
sur ces mesures budgétaires qui
clairement je crois qu'il y a consensus
là-dessus réduisent l'inflation à court
terme en France elle réduisent
l'inflation de deux points environ en
2022 donc c'est assez conséquent mais
néanmoins il faut être vigilance sur la
rapidité à laquelle ces mesures vont
être retirées quand la crise s'estompera
donc j'ai pas faire un cours d'histoire
économique mais il faut savoir que le
une des origines de la grande inflation
des années 70 à laquelle beaucoup
seraient faire vient au fait que les
États-Unis sous concentration Johnson
avait fortement augmenté les dépenses
publiques sans hausse de taxes
concomitante donc c'est à dire aux
dépenses publiques en créant en créant
de la dette donc là vous allez à droite
le la courbe bleue claire c'est
l'évolution des dépenses publiques
américaines déflater par l'inflation
dans les années 60 et vous voyez que ça
très fortement augmenté et que je viens
de vous le dire c'était une des causes
de la hausse de l'inflation dans les
années 70 et vous voyez que le pays
européens donc là on les on les compare
au pays européen aujourd'hui donc depuis
2000 2016-2017 France - Allemagne etc et
on voit que les les hausses de dépenses
publiques sont assez importantes
notamment en Espagne avec la crise de la
covid et comme je viens de vous montrer
graphique de gauche les dépenses
publiques devraient encore augmenter
pour faire face à la crise énergétique
point intéressant je pense la France le
les dépenses publiques des flattées par
le l'inflation sont quasiment revenus à
leur tendance d'après covid donc là la
France n'est pas le plus grand des
pensées
parmi ses voisins
notamment à ce qu'on pourrait croire
donc voilà je tenais à souligner ce
point le point le point de fiscal sur
l'inflation donc sur le site suivant
alors main sur la France donc très
rapidement je crois que mes confrères
ont largement montré les les dernières
indicateurs de climat des affaires
entreprises donc c'est le graphique de
droite effectivement comme
Eric la souligné les enquêtes sont
plutôt résiliantes en France on a à peu
près au moyen de long terme mais
néanmoins on voit sur le secteur
manufacturier un début de dégradation
qui est dû
à un ralentissement très fort dans les
industries chimiques notamment métaux
papier qui sont les industries les plus
énergivores et après vous avez aussi des
effets de répercussion sur les
industries qui dépendent des produits
intermédiaires produits par ces par
notamment le la chimie et par cet effet
de répercussion effectivement donc on
observe un ralentissement assez fort
mais les constructions services
effectivement sont plutôt résilients
pour le moment à gauche vous avez le
sentiment le
l'indicateur de sentiment économique
produit par la Commission européenne de
Bruxelles qui si vous voulez est un un
mix des sentiments sur les ménages et
entreprise et on voit qu'il ralentit
fortement mais il a encore compatible
avec une croissance du PIB français
positive au troisième trimestre donc je
crois que sur ce point là je suis aligné
avec mes confrères sur le slide suivant
néanmoins on pense donc nous à Lyon ce
que l'économie française ne résistera
pas très longtemps et en fait on
s'attend une récession de l'ordre de
moisir aussi pour cent 2023 - 0,6% du 23
pourquoi alors premièrement je crois
l'avoir montré nos voisins sont déjà
rentrés ou vont entrer en récession
d'ici peu je crois leur montrer sur
l'Allemagne et l'Italie donc des effets
de répercussions seront les États-Unis
également je vais les montrer dans le
premier slide mais également si vous
regardez plus précisément dans le cas
français vous avez à gauche par exemple
les
la confiance des consommateurs qui se
dégradent très fortement ce qui n'est
pas étonnant puisque le port d'achat se
dégrade les prix sont élevés et il y a
tout un discours anxiogène sur la crise
du gaz russe mais généralement donc si
on en croit ce graphique les dépenses de
consommation des ménages qui sont encore
très fortes devraient fortement ralentir
dans les dans les trimestres pour chien
et comme vous le savez le la
consommation et le moteur essentiel de
la croissance française et des économies
développées aussi un petit point sur le
marché immobilier donc là c'est un effet
je dirais indirect du resserrement
monétaire très fort de la BCE les
demandes ménage de crédit immobilier
pour finance financer des nouveaux
logements vous le voyez c'est la courbe
qui plonge à droite dans le graphique de
droite signal que l'investissement
logement devrait être très fortement
reculé dans les trimestres prochains
donc un deuxième indicateur pour nous
qui signale une récession pour 2023
récession toutefois je tiens à préciser
relativement modéré de moins Russie pour
cent grâce notamment au soutien des
états sur le slide suivant
donc nous on a une prévision de déficit
public un peu différente de celle du
gouvernement ce qui est logique puisque
le gouvernement s'attend 1% de
croissance l'année prochaine on s'attend
à -0 aussi pour cent donc à force
théorie nous prévisions de déficit
public divergent un petit peu pour 2023
le gouvernement est à moins 5 % on est à
-5,5 % depuis et B donc on s'attend une
dégradation du défi public pour l'année
prochaine je tiens aussi à noter le fait
que les besoins de consolidation
budgétaire pour la France sont très
importants donc là on a on a simulé
l'effet d'une hausse de 100 points de
base des taux d'intérêt d'emprunt sur la
dette française et d'ailleurs sur nos
voisins européens vous avez Almagne
Italie Espagne qui sont représentés
également et c'est ça serait un coup
supplémentaire pour les finances
publiques de l'ordre de 70 milliards
d'euros alors bien évidemment ça met
beaucoup de temps pour que les taux les
taux du marché se répercutent sur les
taux effectifs d'emprunt puisque la
dette française est à peu près de 8 à 9
ans de maturité donc ça prend un certain
temps néanmoins
je crois important de souligner que les
besoins de consolidation budgétaires
vont peser sur la croissance effective
des prochaines années et c'est pour ça
que nous sommes un peu plus pessimistes
que le gouvernement sur les prévisions
jusqu'à 2027 de la croissance du PIB
donc en terme de croissance effective
alors ensuite si on rentre plus dans le
suivant s'il vous plaît merci
effectivement c'est en plus sur les
questions de croissance potentielle de
moyen terme qui est l'objet de cette
réunion c'est vrai qu'en France le taux
de chômage déstructurel à un peu baissé
on est environ à 7,2 % de chômage
actuellement ce qui est historiquement
faible alors on pense qu'à la fois des
facteurs structurels qui expliquent que
le chômage baisse en France n'est pas
qu'en France d'ailleurs dans tous les
dans toutes les économies annoncées une
des raisons c'est que c'est tout
simplement le vieillissement
démographique il est bien connu que les
les personnes plus
âgées par rapport aux personnes plus
jeunes ou un taux de chômage plus faible
et pourquoi c'est parce que elles ont
plus de compétences techniques elles ont
plus d'expérience donc qui sont beaucoup
plus facilement employables vous
pourriez sur le graphique de gauche les
moins de 25 ans ont un taux de chômage
d'environ 18% 20%. alors que les
personnes de plus de 49 ans ont un taux
de chômage autour de 5%. donc
effectivement puisque la structure
démographique est en train de changer
cela cela explique en partie le fait que
les les
salariés deviennent plus facilement
employables
vous avez aussi le les effets des
réformes à venir alors nous on a pris
l'hypothèse que la réforme de
l'assurance chômage sera
voté c'est une hypothèse qu'on a fait
dans notre scénario et on pense que ça
va renforcer la tendance à la baisse du
chômage structurel donc on est on est
plutôt plutôt optimiste sur les
perspectives d'emploi en France et
pourquoi tout simplement si vous
comparez par exemple la France Graphique
de droite à l'OCDE sur ce qu'on appelle
le taux implicite de taxation à
l'entraîne emploi donc quand vous êtes
au chômage en France et que vous rentrez
en emploi si vous faites 100 de revenus
en plus grâce
à votre nouvel emploi vous avez à peu
près 75% qui part en hausse de taxes ou
en baisse d'aide donc à force Yori si le
si c'est très fort réduit un petit peu
les aides à l'assurance chômage vous
avez vous êtes plus incité en tout cas
vous perdez moins quand vous passez de
désactiver enfin de chômage plutôt à
emploi et donc vous voyez le par exemple
les la moyenne au CD est quand même très
important puisqu'elle a la moyenne au
CDA c'est moins de 65% de ce taux
implicite de taxation à l'entrée en
emploi donc donc on pense que les
perspectives du chômage structurel sont
plutôt orientées à la baisse et on
s'entend on s'attend à tout de chômage
structurel de l'ordre de 7,2 % contre 8
% environ actuellement
17 2027 sur le slide suivant
alors on pense néanmoins que pour
vraiment arriver ce qu'on appelle au
plein emploi alors je sais pas
exactement ce que ça veut dire plein
d'emploi mais si plein d'emploi ça veut
dire des taux de chômage de 5% 4% comme
on a ou être Atlantique comment au Japon
comme on a au Royaume-Uni on pense qu'on
sera clairement pas là parce que
disons qu'il faudrait combiner plusieurs
réformes alors à droite vous avez par
exemple les on est assez pessimiste sur
le niveau général de formation de la
population avec une dégradation de
plusieurs décennies des enquêtes en
termes de niveau de lecture de
mathématiques et de sciences donc là
vous voyez encore comparer la France à
l'OCDE un score plus élevé indiquant un
niveau plus mauvais plus dégradé donc
dans tous les domaines la France est
quand même un niveau bien plus dégradé
par rapport à la moyenne de l'ecde et on
va on va dire les choses s'améliorer
d'après les dernières enquêtes en tout
cas et puis également
le fameux coin fiscal au social donc à
gauche qui vous montre encore une fois
la France comparée à quelques voisins
c'est à dire le coin fiscal au social
c'est quoi c'est le niveau des
prélèvements cotisations sociales plus
taxation des revenus en pourcentage du
travail alors pourquoi il est élevé en
France tout le monde le sait même s'il a
un petit peu baissé depuis 2012 2013
pourquoi je vous montre ça c'est parce
que nous on pense que tant que le
salaire net en France n'augmentera pas
il sera difficile de
de stimuler
l'offre de travail donc il sera
difficile de stimuler les chômeurs qui
repasseraient à l'emploi donc ça revient
un petit peu l'argument que j'ai j'ai
évoqué précédemment donc donc pour nous
la question du salaire net donc mieux
payé mieux rémunérer le travail est une
question importante pour
en plus de la formation pour pour
baisser durablement le chômage vers un
niveau dite dit de plein emploi autour
de 5% de chômage structurel
sur le slide suivant
alors là c'est sur l'investissement donc
je vais être assez rapide je suis plutôt
d'accord avec mes confrères que les les
perspectives l'investissement sont
plutôt favorables et ont été plutôt
surpris à la hausse depuis la crise de
la covid c'est vrai donc là vous avez à
gauche
l'investissement total en pourcentage du
du PIB donc il est vous le voyez il est
il est en hausse très net depuis 2015
à la fois en termes d'investissement
brut mais également en termes
d'investissement net donc c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour les perspectives de
croissance potentielle puisque
l'investissement c'est un élément
essentiel de la croissance potentielle
et on pense également qu'il y a beaucoup
de rattrapage possible en tout cas de
l'investissement possible dans les
énergies renouvelables donc là vous avez
à droite la France comparait à ses
voisins en termes de d'investissement
privé donc entrepris par le secteur
privé dans les infrastructures
énergétiques en pourcentage du total des
investissements privés et donc vous
voyez que depuis la période poscoïde la
France est en retard on a un peu moins
de 30% de de l'investissement privé
total dans les énergies renouvelables
alors que vous avez des chiffres près de
60% aux États-Unis par exemple l'Italie
également fait très fort soit en 5% des
investissements privés infrastructures
sont dans l'énergie et les
infrastructures de renouvelables donc on
pense qu'il y a un potentiel de
croissance de l'investissement qui reste
plutôt favorable malgré un durcissement
en cours des conditions monétaires avec
la BCE qui augmente très fortement cette
eau voilà si vous allez sur le graphique
suivant et je crois que c'est mon
dernier slide alors nous par contre
c'est vrai qu'on a une croissance
potentielle de 0,9 je crois que c'est
comme c'est comme moi que ces codes
Denis donc plutôt pessimiste enfin en
tout cas beaucoup plus faible que le
gouvernement qui a 1,35 et comme je vous
l'expliquais c'est pas sur l'emploi
qu'on est on diverge ce n'est pas sur
l'investissement non plus qu'en
divergent mais c'est vraiment sont
plutôt les la croissance tendance de la
productivité notamment la productivité
des facteurs en généralement technique
alors il faut savoir que
les chocs énergétiques généralement
entraînent un ralentissement fort et
brutal de la productivité donc là vous
avez à droite je vous ai mis dans les
années 80
les chocs pétroliers
70 pardon en France donc vous avez la
croissance de la productivité du travail
tout simplement donc les PIB diviser par
le nombre de salariés nombre de
personnes travaillant et vous voyez que
dans suite au choc pétrolier de 73 et de
79 dans les deux cas vous avez un
ralentissement extrêmement fort de la
productivité qui n'a jamais retrouvé son
niveau d'avant sur pétrolier or le choc
actuel qu'on a qui est à chaque gazier
enfin un choc pétrolier un choc gazier
quand on compare ça
aux années 74 79 donc c'est le graphique
de gauche là j'ai repris un graphique de
confrères de capital économics on voit
qu'on la France n'est pas le pays le
plus affecté puisque les moins
dépendants du gaz relativement que
beaucoup de ses voisins mais néanmoins
vous voyez donc la France est à peu près
milieu gauche du graphique on voit que
ce choc gazier du à la coupure des app
raisonnement russe est environ quasiment
à 2% de PIB de prélèvement sur
l'économie française en 1974 et 79
c'était un peu plus élevé mais guerre
plus élevé environ 2,1 2,2 % donc dans
ce contexte nous nous pensons que si la
crise énergétique dure et on pense
qu'elle dure c'est une hypothèse forte
mais on peut en discuter mais en tout
cas c'est notre hypothèse on pense que
le les perspectives de productivité
seront assez faibles puisque notamment
vous aurez une certaine destruction
nutrition industrielle or l'industrie
c'est un des principaux facteurs de
croissance de la productivité en tout
cas plus que les services généralement
donc voilà donc on est plutôt prudent je
dirais sur les perspectives des
productivité ce qui nous amène à une
croissance potentielle de l'ordre de 0,9
pour 100 d'ici à 2027 et je vais
m'arrêter là je crois que j'ai déjà été
assez long merci beaucoup
bien merci messieurs nous avons donc
de deux questions
ou peut-être plus
Monsieur bachel Merci monsieur le
Président beaucoup a été dit que vous
avez pris le temps qu'il fallait je
trouve chacun pour exposer d'ailleurs
vos différences
donc on comprend bien donc
[Musique]
on aimerait bien avoir quand même chacun
alors je pense qu'il y a la plus
exprimée que
et Monsieur dermé c'est l'écart de
production en 2022 le point de départ
parce que c'est important quand on fait
une projection de savoir d'où on part
bon il y a des sujets structurels et a
tendance et on a bien compris qu'elles
étaient à chacun d'entre vous votre
croissance potentielle mais si elle
point de départ donc est-ce que vous
pourriez repréciser votre écart de votre
output de Gap 2022 2023 et
éventuellement
en 2023 moi je trouve que faire de la
prévision économique 2023 effectivement
on peut être comme à dire totalement
dans la littérature économique et dans
le truc très académique parce que on a
un peu l'impression qu'on ne sait pas
dans la dire grand-chose et que les
incertitudes sont d'un autre ordre que
l'ordre économique de l'économie
classique
ou monétaire dont j'ai compris que ce
n'était pas le fort de l'OSCE sur le
niveau des prix mais bon je ne dirai
rien non c'est intense des prix pas le
niveau des prix qui compte il y a eu des
prix Nobel pour ça je crois
c'était une petite remarque au passage
mais j'aime beaucoup votre idée du sur
le le chômage et la baisse de la
productivité qui me semble sujet
vraiment majeur je comprends de la
programmation pure annuelle des finances
publiques
qui montrent l'écart entre les
hypothèses ou c'est peut-être au Conseil
des finances publiques je ne sais plus
qui montre l'écart entre ce que fait le
gouvernement et je veux dire le
consensus forecast qui exprime bien que
grosso modo tout est dans la PGF alors
évidemment c'est pas facile à expliquer
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure mais
l'essentiel de l'écart pour expliquer
les différences de croissance
potentielle c'est la PGF donc on cherche
et je remercie riquière d'avoir
soulevé quelques hypothèses
peut-être d'ailleurs plus que des
hypothèses des choses vraies sur le la
baisse de la productivité du travail moi
je pense aussi qu'il y a le contenu des
de la croissance en emploi
si vous faites si vous remplissez les
hôtels café-restaurant bon vous avez une
productivité qui est extrêmement faible
et ce sont des emplois faiblement
qualifiés ce qui expliquerait en partie
en partie aussi c'est une moi je crois
la somme des hypothèses
on est d'accord
d'accord
mais finalement le chômage structurel
donc où le plein d'emploi plus
exactement pour la fin de la période
j'ai envie de dire quel est votre niveau
et est-ce que vous y croyez
[Musique]
donc deux questions quel est votre
croissance potentielle 20223 enfin les
là où tout Gap 20223 et
la fin 2027 est-ce qu'on y croit est-ce
qu'on n'y croit pas au plein emploi
merci bien
Monsieur Didier Rambaud
le Président on va essayer de se
remonter le moral l'élément positif que
j'ai entendu à travers vous trois c'est
quand même le niveau d'épargne qui est
quand même assez important vous parlez
même
Eric et hier de surépargne et rien que
pour la France d'ailleurs de 170
milliards d'euros il me semble ça c'est
quelque chose de nouveau par rapport aux
crises qu'on a connu dans le passé
qu'on n'avait pas donc moi j'avais envie
de dire une question toute simple c'est
comment on utilise on mobilise ce niveau
de d'épargne est-ce que est-ce qu'on
c'est plus vers la consommation
d'encourage la consommation
l'investissement productif c'est un
mixte des deux voilà j'aimerais avoir
votre avis à tous les trois et puis
peut-être une question sur l'inflation
aussi parce que le dérèglement
climatique étant là donc la fonte des
glaces tout ça va malheureusement libère
des dévirus
et donc on aura d'autres pandémies et
donc des chocs d'inflation et je veux
dire voilà en quoi comment les
économistes peuvent nous aider à
effectivement comment on peut juguler
cette quoi à chaque fois qui arrive et
qui casse ses reprises d'activité merci
Monsieur Michel Grey s'est rajouté à la
liste
merci donc merci de l'ensemble des
présentations et de vos analyses qui
montrent bien qu'effectivement il y a un
décalage entre les prévisions
gouvernementales aujourd'hui et les
prévisions que vous pouvez effectuer
tout à l'heure a été évoqué le l'impact
de la retraite sur
l'amélioration du du de la croissance et
du PIB
simplement est-ce que l'impact il est
immédiat je veux dire par là que il
faudra du temps quand même avant que la
réforme de la retraite produit ses
effets puisque l'allongement ne peut se
faire quasi automatiquement c'est une
première question une deuxième
est-ce que ce dossier ne risque pas
d'entraîner
une réduction de l'activité je veux dire
par là que les mouvements sociaux qui
s'annoncent à l'évocation de ce sujet
risque de perturber significativement
dans le sens les perspectives
économiques que l'on peut établir est-ce
que vous sentez aussi qu'il y a à risque
là-dessus ensuite
la baisse des impôts de production
est-ce que vous pensez que cela peut
avoir un impact sur le PIB à ce que
l'impact sera assez rapide notamment les
8 milliards de baisse d'impôts de
production qui sont évoqués voilà et
puis dire des points peut-être valider à
l'emploi comme comme vous effectivement
c'est d'armée je pense que le niveau de
de plein emploi il est plutôt autour de
6 quelque chose comme ça compte tenu des
dispositifs de solidarité que l'on a
dans le dans notre pays et qui montre
bien que cela
mais le niveau de pleine emploi ou
la capacité à trouver de la main
d'oeuvre un niveau supérieur à ce que
l'on observe dans beaucoup de pays où il
n'y a pas un grand nombre de systèmes de
solidarité qui permettent de continuer à
bénéficier de d'une situation de Dinant
en quelque sorte est-ce que vous
partagez cette analyse
monsieur lamanie Marc laminy oui merci
monsieur le Président merci à nos trois
intervenants pour les trois documents
j'irai très complet qui nous donne un
aperçu global l'échelon national mais
surtout mondial
au moins j'aurais juste une ou deux
trois interrogations quoi c'est très
difficile à faire des
prévisions sur
à court terme on va dire
est-ce que vous avez pu mesurer je
dirais les bons vous avez évoqué
largement les conséquences de la crise
sanitaire mais réellement les
conséquences de la crise sanitaire d'un
côté puis de l'autre côté on parle
beaucoup des aléas climatiques qui ont à
coup sûr aussi un impact
non négligeable je vous remercie
on commence vous souhaitez commencer ou
on aurait pu prendre
alors
je vais essayer de
répondre à la plupart des questions et
même si possible à toutes sur les cartes
de production
donc comme je l'ai évoqué nous estimons
plutôt que nous sommes en fermeture des
cadres de production pas forcément des
garde de production positif mais on est
pour l'instant on est en écart de
production fermée ça ne veut pas dire
pour autant que on ne peut pas encore
avoir une baisse du du chômage parce
qu'effectivement dans ce cas ça voudrait
dire qu'on considère qu'on l'a dit Eric
le chômage culturel à hauteur de ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui donc le taux de
chômage est à 7 grosso modo en ce moment
est-ce que c'est est-ce qu'on est à 7
quand on est au chômage structurel ce
chômage structurel peut continuer à
baisser et ça ça va renvoyer à la
question sur sur la fois sur l'impact
des des retraites et donc cette question
aussi de crédibilité du retour au plan
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut arriver encore à
faire baisser le chômage de structurel
mais plus
plus on s'a à des populations qui sont
éloignées dans l'emploi plus cela a un
coût important les personnes qui sont
pour l'instant en dehors de l'emploi
sont les personnes qui ont le plus
faible niveau de formation initiale et
qu'il faut pouvoir réinsérer dans
l'emploi quand on regarde la les taux
d'emploi en France par catégorie de
formation initiale il y a aucun problème
sur le taux d'emploi des très formés on
est tout à fait comparable à ce que l'on
va trouver chez nos équivalents
européens il y a pas de problème non
plus pour ceux qui ont un niveau de
formation intermédiaire on est à peu
près en zone euro en revanche il y a
bien un écart c'est sur le taux d'emploi
des personnes qui ont le plus faible
niveau de formation initiale et donc
faire baissé le taux de chômage
structurel ça veut dire remettre en
emploi des personnes qui en sont très
éloignées et donc ça ça va être plus
compliqué si vous voulez parce qu'il
faut faire un investissement de la part
des entreprises qui c'est un
investissement en termes de formation et
ça va aussi avoir et là je partage tout
à fait le point qui a évoqué Eric c'est
que on peut pas tout avoir en même temps
c'est-à-dire que si on parvient encore à
faire baisser le taux de chômage
peut-être que rien de productivité que
l'on peut espérer on est retrouvera pas
donc il y a une forme de trades qui peut
s'installer entre les évolutions de
l'emploi et les évolutions de
productivité comme comme vous l'avez
comme vous l'avez souligné mais c'est
bien aussi au regard de la spécificité
des personnes qui sont en ordre de
l'emploi me semble-t-il qu'il faut qu'il
faut interroger
ça fait peut-être un point sur l'impact
des retraites
l'impact des retraites effectivement on
peut pas en attendre un impact immédiat
en termes de taux d'emploi additionnel
parce qu'il y a des habitudes qui sont à
changer et une illustration en clair
c'est le taux d'emploi des 60 64 ans
30%. donc on s'est habitué à ne pas
mettre dans l'emploi à ne pas mettre non
plus dans les processus de formation des
personnes qui sont au fur et à mesure
qu'elles s'approchent de l'âge du départ
à la retraite donc il y a tout un
ensemble de d'habitudes qu'il faut
chasser dans le mode de fonctionnement
des entreprises dans le mode aussi de
représentation des salariés
parce que c'est l'insertion dans une
formation le fait que d'une entreprise
aussi le fait de de salariés donc
comment est-ce qu'on fait en sorte
d'accompagner les personnes pour
qu'elles puissent être plus longtemps
dans l'emploi parce qu'elles font aussi
évoluer leurs compétences la
transformation de l'emploi dans sa
composition est tout à fait tout à fait
saisissante et ça va se prolonger donc
on ne peut pas en attendant un impact
immédiat mais il me semble que l'impact
était assez certain en terme de
d'augmentation du potentiel de
production qui peut être associé à cette
évolution de la de la retraite même
voilà la temporalité est assez
compliquée d'une certaine manière il y a
presque plus facile de la faire de la
prévision à long terme que faire de la
prévision à court terme c'est
on voit à peu près ce qu'il faudrait
mobiliser mais le temps de propagation
effectivement assez
assez long
peut-être qu'à court terme est-ce qu'on
peut s'appuyer sur sur une épargne qui
peut se réinvestir
je pense que l'épargne il faut faire
attention à un point il y a quand même
une érosion assez forte de la valeur de
l'épargne qui s'effectue c'était pas une
se retrouve sur des déplacements
financiers on se retrouve sur des dépôts
qui en réalité provoque une érosion de
cette de cette valeur de l'épargne donc
pour l'instant je parle bien d'érosion
je parle pas de disparition de
l'assurépan mais cette cette érosion est
quand même assez forte et notamment en
zone euro donc plus le temps passe plus
l'augmentation des prix se fait forte
moins la capacité de stimulation par une
éventuelle réinjection de cette épargne
dans le circuit économique ce sera sera
important donc dans ce cas comment
est-ce qu'on peut utiliser pas l'épargne
de manière un peu différente pas
forcément avec une consommation
additionnelle mais en la fléchant vers
d'autres usages de notre point de vue
enfin avec ces codes nous avons
développé quelques nous avons fait
quelques papiers pour dire que c'est
l'arlésienne qu'il faut arriver à faire
à transformer c'est à dire qui est de la
mise en cohérence de besoins fonds
propres très important d'autant plus
important qu'on a à faire la transition
énergétique et la transition énergétique
ne se fait pas faire du financement
d'endettement du financement par de la
dette se fait par du financement de haut
de bilan se fait par du financement en
fonds propres et donc c'est comme
toujours c'est la même c'est la même
question que l'on a de manière quasi
permanente comment est-ce qu'on fait en
sorte de associer l'épargne abondante
avec des fonds propres ça veut dire
quand même aussi une autre question
c'est que le canal sur lequel est
branché jusqu'à présent les pagnes c'est
le canal du financement de l'État
la faible la faible dette publique donc
ça veut dire de la réallocation ça veut
dire peut-être une augmentation plus
forte des conditions de financement de
des pouvoirs publics si on fait le choix
d'arriver à plugger l'épargne plus le
financement de fonds propres donc c'est
c'est vraiment des équilibres qui sont
assez assez fins et que l'on peut
bousculer comme je sais que je serai
attendu et que je sais que Eric serait
déçu que je ne parle pas de la baisse
des impôts de production je vais te
faire plaisir
Eric donc la baisse des impôts de
production
c'est quelque chose que nous nous
défendons avec ses codes ne serait-ce
que pour pouvoir se mettre en harmonie
avec ce qui se passe dans l'ensemble
européen on a à valeur ajoutée
comparable on a 35 milliards d'impôts de
production en plus en France
relativement à la moyenne de l'Europe
c'est plus vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne mais
compara-nous à la moyenne de l'Europe
maintenant baisser les impôts on ne peut
pas faire des propositions de baisse
d'impôt sans dire que mon finance cette
baisse d'impôt faire continuer à faire
des baisses constantes posent un
problème donc
nous avons jamais été des fans absolus
moi en particulier au sein de Rex école
mais là je m'engage plus personnellement
de Rex et la vie est pas complètement
tranchée mais peu importe ça c'est notre
cuisine interne
[Rires]
de mon point de vue en fait il vaut
mieux créer des conditions de générer de
la production qui ont ensuite on peut
sur laquelle on peut prélever du de
l'impôt que d'empêcher la production ou
en tout cas que de brider la production
et donc s'il y a c'est un arbitrage à
faire c'est améliorer les conditions de
production parce que on est comparable à
ce que font nos partenaires nos
concurrents et puis bien ensuite on
prélève le résultat qui est qui est
généré ça me paraît quand même beaucoup
plus sain de fonctionner de cette
manière et donc là encore c'est un
équilibre qui est à trouver entre ce que
l'on va faire en termes de réduction de
d'impôts de production et ce que l'on
peut faire en termes de prélèvement sur
la ressource qui se trouve générée mais
on génère en taxe de la ressource on ne
taxe pas les conditions de création de
cette ressource
pendant je vais peut-être pas répondu
de compléter alors globalement c'est
vrai que pour répondre à la question
pleine emploi vous voyez si vous croyez
si l'autre coup de Gap est au niveau que
l'on croit nous le chômage structurel il
est à 6 %. depuis depuis une évaluation
qu'on a qu'on a réalisé avec Xavier
Timbaud depuis un moment aux autres si
c'est demi enfin entre 6-3 et 6,4
d'accord donc c'est vrai
qu'effectivement le jour on aura fermé
l'autre coup de Gap on sera à ce niveau
là 6 3 6 4 et donc pour arriver au plein
emploi c'est à 5 ou 4 et demi mais
effectivement il faut quelques réformes
alors il y en a certaines qui ont été
évoquées par Maxime moi je pense que la
principale c'est pas celle-ci c'est
l'immobilier je pense que parmi les
raisons qui expliquent pourquoi il y a
une il y a une mauvaise appariement
entre l'offre et la demande l'immobilier
fait partie des des éléments qui sont
pas soumis en avant il y a maintenant
des études suffisamment suffis
importante alors pour la mobilité mais
même vous voyez le mal logement c'est
maintenant assez bien étudié que le mal
logement ces sources de mauvaise
intégration sur le marché du travail
c'est source d'échec scolaires des
enfants vous voyez si vous cherchez
pourquoi on a des mauvaises performances
on peut très bien dire c'est le système
éducatif qui est pas bon vous regardez
sinon vous voyez les études du Collège
de France les études du Collège de
France qui qui arrivent à dire à
détecter à la fin de la maternelle début
du CP donc on en est pas encore aux
compétences à la fin de la maternelle
début du CP ils arrivent à dire à 82 %
qui va échouer et qui va être décrocheur
à 16 ans vous voyez c'est pas le système
éducatif qui a à remettre c'est pas que
le système éducatif comment ils arrivent
à le voir ils font pas des tests de
est-ce que tu es bon en maths ils disent
que font tes parents donc au moins de
mètres carrés tu vis et c'est une
batterie de tests et après il dit c'est
toi tu as 82 % d'échoué bon je pense que
si on si mais ils le disent pas bien sûr
mais dans dans leur et oui
le mal logement ces sources d'inégalités
de mauvaises intégration du marché du
travail de d'absentéisme d'absentéisme
mais voyez donc quand vous cherchez les
pistes voilà le le fait d'avoir fait une
France de propriétaire une fois vous
êtes propriétaire vous êtes fixé dans
une région d'accord vous avez du mal à
bouger donc ouais bon bien sûr que la
compétence tout ça on va pas dire compte
mais c'est tellement des idées qui
circulent on sait pas comment faire je
vais dire que le logement à mon avis
c'est des pistes qui ne sont pas assez
évoquées et qui pourraient permettre de
passer de ce système de chômage
structural au plein emploi d'accord bon
et ça permettrait aussi pourquoi pas une
fois que vous logez bien tout le monde
bah vous pouvez être un peu plus dur sur
les salaires mais là aujourd'hui se
considérait que il faut baisser le
salaire bah oui c'est compliqué est-ce
que vous n'arrivez pas à vous loger déjà
avec votre salaire vous voyez c'est ça
qu'on a donc il faut essayer
effectivement d'avoir des logements de
bonne qualité et pas cher bon c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire sur bien sûr
que la crise sociale vous voyez
peut-être que ce qui est ce qui
différencie notre scénario de celui
présenté par pas possible c'est en
partie il a pris un risque de dire voilà
il y a un choc supplémentaire qu'on n'a
pas pris c'est le rationnement bon entre
nous moi je bon ok c'est c'est preuve de
courage on sait pas dire nous si il y
aura du rationnement et donc on n'a pas
mis cette incidence mais bien entendu ça
fait partie des risques mais voyez que
si je crois mais dis-moi si je me trompe
il y a un point et demi à peu près de
choc s'il y a du rationnement ben vous
voyez vous passez de 0,6 - 1 et demi
vous allez être à moins bon ok allez à
peu près c'est bon est-ce qu'on en est
sûr comment on peut faire c'est très
compliqué et bien on va essayer de
l'éviter au maximum me semble-t-il et
qui peut pas y avoir le double peine et
les prix et la quantité bon on a fait ce
choix là mais c'est un la crise sociale
par contre c'est à notre choc qui est
devant nous et qui n'est pas dans l'être
bon voilà moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui
tout de même on l'a on sait pas non plus
le détecter quand est-ce qu'une crise
sociale ou une crise climatique va
arriver parce que bien entendu vous avez
raison de dire que il va y avoir des
chocs sanitaires qui vont arriver est-ce
qu'on va mieux les gérer que le premier
sans doute mais il y aura des incidences
ça fera pas moins 8 à chaque fois dis
autrement mais il y aura des incidences
oui c'est évident des catastrophes
naturelles qui vont faire des ruptures
d'approvisionnement ou potentiellement
des nouveaux virus qui vont donc ça on
sait pas le prévoir donc tout ça c'est
bien sûr hors choc exceptionnel la crise
sociale entre nous elle est l'attente et
en 2019 elle était déjà là on l'a pas
oublié mais elle était présente alors
que bon globalement ça allait plus ou
moins bien d'accord bon depuis 2019 le
taux de pauvreté s'est stabilisé nous
dignité donc très bien grâce au
quoiqu'il en coûte ok mais les
inégalités ont augmenté puisque
globalement les ménages aisés ont su
épargné donc cette sur épargne ce qui
rend difficile le le comment ils vont ça
va être utilisé c'est que c'est
concentré cette sur épargne nous dit le
Conseil d'analyse économique il va
falloir une deuxième étude pour le
confirmer c'est concentré sur les 80%
les plus aisés donc quand on dit il y a
une sur épargne en fait elle est pas sur
tous les ménages elle est concentrée sur
les 20% les plus riches donc les
inégalités augmentent parce que des
ménages aisés ont su épargné à tout le
monde d'accord et parce que pendant les
crises normalement vous avez les actifs
qui chutent les prix d'immobilier qui
baissent ou les bourses qui baisent là
non donc aménage aisé finalement assuré
pendant la crise et a vu ses actifs
augmenter bah il est plus riches
maintenant qu'avant la crise ce qui
n'est pas le cas pour tout le monde donc
vous voyez c'est pas une question de
taux de pauvreté c'est une question
juste d'inégalité qui augmente bon vous
rajoutez à cela une un choc énergétique
sur les prix mais ça alors pour le coup
c'est très inégalitaire le poids de
l'énergie ou l'alimentaire n'est pas le
même quand on est dans le premier des
cils ou dans le dernier décide donc
cette inflation n'est pas la même quand
on dit c'est 5% d'inflation c'est pas 5%
pour tout le monde c'est beaucoup plus
pour des ménages que pour d'autres bon
ça c'est source d'inégalités si ensuite
votre narratif et votre et de dire
demain on va faire des économies sur
l'assurance chômage et sur les retraites
ce qui avait provoqué le conflit social
en 2019 quand les inégalités étaient
moins importantes il y a une chance
quand même très importante que ça
revienne que ça revienne enfin voilà ou
alors mais bon puisque on en est pas sûr
on le met pas mais entre nous on serait
pas surpris donc voyez et là on en vient
aux impôts de production quelque part si
vous dites de tout manière on
aujourd'hui on avait déjà avant la crise
des niveaux de de dette publique
importantes et de déficit important donc
il fallait effectivement être tenté de
réduire et les impôts et les dépenses
publiques d'accord mais à ça est venu se
rajouter quasiment 200 milliards de
dettes supplémentaires et on se dit bah
tout ça on le fait sans augmenter les
impôts bon ben ouais donc là on a
rajouté une contrainte de 200 milliards
ça va être compliqué de dire qu'on va le
faire tout ça en continuant à baisser
les impôts je pense que dans le dans le
dans le dans le discours social ça va
être compliqué parce que ça va être
forcément sur la dépense publique qui
est va un peu plus à déménage modeste et
donc bah oui il y aura quand même un
sentiment enfin moi je vois pas comment
une crise sociale ne va pas être
perturbée quelque part les le
quinquennat à venir on ne le met pas
d'accord parce qu'on sait pas lire mais
bien entendu que ça fait partie de nos
aléas qui sont qui sont plus négatif un
dernier point sur le climat et après
c'est que globalement vous voyez
aujourd'hui l'Académie et c'est pas de
savoir est-ce que la croissance provoque
du réchauffement climatique ça on dit
allez c'est sûr c'est Voltaire Rousseau
c'est Rousseau qui gagne haut la main
sur ce sur ce sur ce schéma là mais
l'économie c'est celle de se dire est-ce
que le réchauffement climatique est bon
pour la croissance économique oui c'est
question un peu saugrenu mais en tout
cas il s'impose dans ce sens là que nous
disent aujourd'hui résultat académique à
cette question là est-ce que le
réchauffement climatique qui est annoncé
que ça soit naturel ou lié à l'action
humaine est-ce que c'est bon pour la
croissance le résultat est ça dépend ça
dépend du niveau de température initiale
si on part d'un niveau faible de
température un réchauffement
supplémentaire peut être bon pour la
croissance en revanche à un certain
niveau de température tout réchauffement
supplémentaire va provoquer une
décroissance d'accord ça c'est le
résultat simplifié de tous ces modèles
là ensuite ils font leur projection et
là vous voyez la catastrophe mais quand
vous voyez qu'il faut voir la carte
d'accord c'est que bien sûr l'incidence
va être beaucoup plus fort dans le sud
que dans le Nord d'accord et donc vous
voyez alors nous ça avoir une incidence
chez nous mais
ridicule par rapport à ce qui peut se
produire dans les pays du Sud et les
conséquences que ça va avoir sur
l'immigration et sur les prématoires
dans les années à venir et donc oui
comment et donc la question qu'on doit
se poser c'est si on fait rien comment
on va gérer ces flux migratoires
gigantesques qui vont venir certains
peuvent vous dire ça va vous faire de la
croissance potentielle ça vous faire
beaucoup de population d'accord et donc
du coup il va falloir réviser un peu
tous nos jugements sur la croissance
potentielle doit te dire ça va être de
merde un choc tellement violent qui ça
sera quasiment ingérable et là tous vos
calculs sur le taux de chômage etc c'est
quand même alors là on n'est pas à 2027
quand on fait ce type de calcul c'est
plutôt à l'horizon 2050 d'accord mais
attention à ces éléments-là qui vont
perturber énormément la lecture dans les
dans les prochaines années
et on va terminer par Monsieur Maxime
Darney je vais essayer d'être un peu
plus synthétique alors sur le l'écart
d'outil cap il me reste combien de temps
d'ailleurs
nous on a le gouvernement je crois à
moins à l'argument en 2022 donc on a -09
donc on est on est plutôt aligné je
suspecte que les l'écart entre le
gouvernement et nous vient encore une
fois au calcul de la fameuse PGF qui est
très difficile à mesurer et puis nous
notre vue c'est plutôt que la crise de
la covid
a perturbé durablement les chaînes de
valeur je crois en a beaucoup parlé
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire concrètement
c'est quand l'entreprise la gestion des
stocks devient beaucoup plus compliquée
dans la période post covid avant le
covid vous savez les entreprises et dans
une logique de Just In Time c'est à dire
il faut les réduire le montant des
stocks le plus possible parce que les
stocks ça coûte cher ça brûle de la
trésorerie notamment et depuis la covid
on a bien vu que très rapidement c'est
ces chaînes d'approvisionnement pouvait
être mise en difficulté voilà vous avez
le covid chinois etc et donc on est
passé plutôt une logique de Justin case
c'est à dire que maintenant les
entreprises sont beaucoup plus prudentes
elles vont anticiper plus de choc à
l'avenir climatique chinois virus ou je
ne sais quoi d'autre qui pourrait sortir
de la glace et donc on pense que vous
aurez des niveaux de stock plus élevés
dans les prochaines années ce qui coûte
plus cher et ce qui selon nous affecte
le l'apgf la fameuse PGF donc ça c'est
peut-être un point de de
qui explique l'écart entre entre le
gouvernement et nous
alors ensuite sur sur le fameux surpris
d'appargne oui j'ai pas trop d'autres
éléments à ajouter par rapport à mes
confrères on est assez sceptique sur le
fait que c'était épargne pour être
dépensé et booster la croissance dans
les dans les années à venir donc comme
ça a été dit déjà c'était épargne et
d'abord avant tout accumulée parmi les
revenus les plus élevés qui ont
propension beaucoup plus faible à
consommer deuxièmement l'épargne et rode
très rapidement l'inflation excusez-moi
Hérode très rapidement c'était épargne
et je tiens à répéter mon point sur les
besoins de consolidation budgétaire là
les les salariés les agents ils
comprennent bien que les niveaux
d'endettement public les taux d'intérêts
qui vont être durablement plus élevés
parce que la BCE maintenant elle change
c'est fini les politiques de taux zéro
donc vous avez une équation budgétaire
qui se complique très nettement et quand
vous êtes ménage qu'est-ce que vous
voyez est-ce que je vais dépenser cette
épargne dans mon compte en banque non
moi je préfère la garder on sait jamais
Eric aime ok peut-être des hausses de
taxe oui c'est très possible nous on a
du mal à croire les baisses de taxes
et durable sur le sur la fin du
quinquennat donc quand vous êtes ménage
vous dites bah non je vais garder un
petit peu de côté plutôt que de dépenser
dans ces temps d'incertitudes et donc
voilà donc on est très sceptique sur ce
sur ce vecteur
je crois que j'ai un dernier point que
je voulais aborder oui encore une fois
sur le plan d'emploi j'ai pas trop de
dissonance avec mes confrères je pense
que le vrai problème français c'est
niveau de formation le manque de
compétences techniques
de venir évoquer les chiffres pour les
les salariés ou les gens qui ont le
niveau de le niveau de formation le plus
faible c'est vraiment là dessus je pense
qu'il faut tout miser encore plus que
sur les baisses de taxes mais également
c'est également sur le ce que rapporte
le travail si vous voulez encore une
fois le salaire net en France est faible
donc les gens quand vous allez me
demander pourquoi vous ne vendez pas
dans dans le marché de l'emploi ils vont
vous dire moi je veux pas gagner
un petit SMIC le coût de la vie est très
élevé donc je voudrais un salaire plus
net et en France on a des marges de
manœuvre on a beaucoup de marge de
manœuvre même pour augmenter le salaire
net
après bien sûr faudra les financer ces
baisses de cotisations sociales c'est
baisse de taxes encore une question mais
j'insiste vraiment sur l'aspect incité
l'offre de travail rendre les gens
beaucoup plus attirés pour travailler
parce qu'ils ont des perspectives de
salaire meilleur que ce qu'il aurait
proposé et donc c'est des facteurs et je
pense à ne pas négliger que et que
beaucoup d'économistes négligent
peut-être un peu trop
donc voilà je crois que c'est à peu près
tout ce que j'avais rajouté par rapport
à mes confrères
je crois que
disons que Monsieur feront a souhaité
une ultime réaction avant et je vous
j'ai
usé du privilège de la proximité
effectivement
oui pour pour compléter pas jusqu'à
l'horizon 2050 sur l'aspect l'aspect
coût associé à la transition mais le FMI
a sorti une évaluation récente sur
justement les coûts de l'atténuation et
la croissance en moins que cela pouvait
procurer si on fait véritablement les
les éléments non pas de transition mais
d'atténuation des conséquences du choc
climatique on est sur 0,05 ça paraît pas
beaucoup mais 0,2 ou jusqu'à 0,2 points
de croissance en moins à moyen terme
donc là aussi c'est une pièce qui est
assez immédiate si vous voulez par
rapport à l'horizon sur lequel vous avez
à travailler par an et puis en outre
point qu'il faut garder vraiment très
présent à l'esprit c'est que le choc que
l'on connaît et je réagis à
l'observation que faisait Maxime tout à
l'heure c'est quand on compare la
situation
par rapport au choc énergétique de 73 79
c'est qu'on était sur un choc de prix
mondial d'un prix qui concerne un bien
dont la valorisation est à peu près la
même dans les différentes zones là le
choc il concerne une énergie qui a un
prix local le gaz donc en 73-79 ça
concerne le pétrole la désormais ça
concerne le gaz et ses conséquences en
termes d'électricité ce qui veut dire
que l'on déplace radicalement les
conditions de l'exercice compétitif
entre continents en défaveur de l'Europe
et ça ça rajoute une pièce alors certes
il peut se trouver compensé par la
dépréciation de l'euro en partie mais il
faut garder présent à l'esprit je pense
deux un chiffre qui est qui que je
trouve très frappant c'est qu'en gros le
prix du gaz alors ok il a il a baissé
dernièrement si vous le prenez en
septembre par rapport à 2019 c'est x 14
en Europe c'est fois 8 en Asie c'est x 3
aux États-Unis ce qui fait que le prix
du gaz qui a été le double en Europe de
ce qu'il était aux Etats-Unis désormais
il est 7 fois plus élevé qu'aux
États-Unis autrement dit certains pour
regarder la production industrielle en
Chine pardon la production industrielle
en Allemagne c'est 12% de moins depuis
le déclenchement du conflit en Ukraine
donc on a devant nous quand même aussi
des échéances qui sont très immédiates
de par la nature spécifique de ce choc
qui a un choc de nature locale et non
pas mondiale comme lors des précédents
choc énergétiques
c'est juste un dernier point à mettre à
votre connaissance si vous voulez
comparer quand même nos prévisions de
d'emploi et de chômage avec celle du
gouvernement il y a quand même un point
qu'on n'a pas évoqué et qui me paraît
être primordial c'est l'apprentissage et
les hypothèses que vous mettez derrière
l'apprentissage je sais pas ce que mes
mes deux confrères ont fait et voyez si
vous croyez la première ministre il y a
quand même un objectif de 1 million
semble-t-il
d'apprenti dans là vous voyez le choc
enfin nous on y croit absolument pas
parce que budgétairement non mais juste
bizarrement ce n'est pas du tout dans le
budget d'accord mais ça veut dire qu'il
va falloir l'associer à un budget
supplémentaire mais si vous vous mettez
enfin en gros c'est le gros retour des
emplois aidés d'une façon un peu
différente parce que ça veut dire que on
continue à faire la prime de
exceptionnelle de 8000 euros mais qui ne
qui n'est plus exceptionnel qui qui
reste mais ça ça peut vous permettre
d'afficher des taux de chômage beaucoup
plus faibles beaucoup plus faible
puisque vous voyez en gros globalement
ça vous fera 200 à 300 000 emplois
supplémentaires donc pas forcément
chômeur en moins parce que les apprentis
n'étaient pas des forcément dans
l'activité avant mais puisque c'est
quand même concentré dans ça de
population attention à cela enfin donc
globalement une partie peut provenir de
là et vous pouvez afficher des taux de
chômage relativement maîtrisés d'accord
et pas de hausse par une sorte de
traitement social du chômage avec
l'apprentissage je dis pas que c'est une
mauvaise chose mais budgétairement il va
falloir quand même que l'indiquer
donc messieurs merci pour cette revue de
perspective économique
à titre personnel j'ai trouvé
passionnante mais je pense que mes
collègues aussi en dépit de quelques
nuances voire dissonance comme vous avez
pu dire mais globalement c'était très
intéressant merci